Ich bin sehr. Ich bin sehr schrecklich, dass die Leute die nicht wissen. Ich bin sehr schrecklich, dass die Leute die nicht wissen. Ich bin sehr schrecklich, dass die Leute die nicht wissen. Ich bin sehr schrecklich, dass die Leute die nicht wissen. Obwohl es korrekterweise heißt müsste, der Herr Herr Obach. So, ihr seid hergekommen und ihr habt jeder ein Problem mitgebracht. Wo fangen wir denn mal an? Wir hatten mal ein Problem, ein schönes. Also ich fange mal an, ohne jetzt zu sehr in die Tiefe zu gehen, ist bei dieser ganzen Sicherheit eins relativ relevant, nämlich dass man jemanden hat, der die Schlüssel, die da zur Verschlüsselung ausgetauscht werden, bestätigt. Und da gibt es halt verschiedene Entitäten, sogenannte RUT-CA, das nennt man die. Und wenn halt so einer ein Problem hat, gehackt wird, dann können viele Leute Unfug treiben, zumindest die Leute, die es gehackt haben, oder können da viel Unfug treiben. Und das ist gerade geschehen. Diginotar hieß da in den letzten Tagen ein betroffenes Unternehmen, was dann auch in einer Pressemitteilung zugegeben hat, wir wurden da gehackt.
Und deswegen war sozusagen Sicherheit in dem Sinne an einigen Stellen im Netz nicht mehr gegeben.
Also es gibt an irgendeiner Stelle in dieser ganzen Verschlüsselungsgeschichte, gibt es Firmen, die irgendwie wichtig sind. Und wenn die aufgemacht werden, dann ist mal schlecht für das ganze System. Wie das funktioniert, erklären wir gleich. War das alles oder gibt es noch etwas zu berichten? Ich hätte auch noch ein Problem dabei. Dieses kaputte System, wie gerade Wetter es beschrieben hat, hat dazu gefügt, dass ein ganzes Land überwacht werden kann und auch im Augenblick wird. Und auch diverse andere Regime in Nordafrika das gerne benutzen, um ihre Bevölkerung zu überwachen. Genau, das sind nicht nur Firmen, die da solche Sachen ausstellen können, sondern auch Regierungen. Wir halten fest, eine Firma, die irgendwie wichtig ist, ist kaputt gegangen oder aufgemacht worden. Es gibt eine Regierung. Welche ist es, kann man das sagen? Das ist die Regierung des Iran. Die sozusagen diese Technologie zur Verschlüsselung unterlaufen hat, um so Mails abzuhören? Mails, Facebook-Traffic, Google-Mail. Ok, was auch immer quasi. Genau. Ok, wir haben also zwei Probleme. Ich würde mich ja wundern, wenn der Herr Fukami nicht auch noch eins dabei hat.
Ja, und zwar seit ein paar Tagen geistert ein Begriff in den Nachrichten rum unter dem Begriff BEAST. BEAST steht für Browser Exploit Against SSL und TLS. Und da handelt es sich um ein Problem, was eigentlich schon seit langer Zeit bekannt ist. Und zwar etwas, was halt in dem Protokoll begründet ist. Und das haben halt viele über lange Zeit nicht so ernst gesehen und haben gesagt, ja ja, das ist irgendwie zwar ein Problem, aber ist insofern nicht relevant, weil das halt nicht ausnutzbar ist. Und jetzt vor ein paar Tagen gab es eine Sicherheitskonferenz, wo halt im Vorfeld schon gesagt wurde, dass dort dieses Problem vorgestellt wird. Und zwei Leute, Giuliano Rizzo und Tai Duong, haben auf der Eco-Party in Argentinien dieses BEAST vorgestellt, was sozusagen so ein Angriff, der bisher nur als theoretisch galt, tatsächlich durchgeführt werden kann. Aber dazu später auch nochmal mehr.
Aber so ein Angriff ist ja jetzt irgendwie nicht so dramatisch. Was ist denn das Problem an diesem Angriff? Dass er besonders weitreichend ist, dass jeder ihn machen kann?
Er ist nicht so ganz trivial. Es ist nicht so, dass es jetzt irgendwie so ein Exploit ist, der unbedingt unter allen Möglichkeiten existiert. Aber er ist schon so kritisch, dass dort die Browserhersteller und die Betriebssystemhersteller mit Hochdruck an Lösungen arbeiten, weil dort eben dadurch, dass man über lange Zeit dieses Problem völlig ignoriert hat, dort halt sehr, sehr starke Inkompatibilitäten auftreten und dass den ganzen Browserherstellern auf die Füße fällt.
Okay, also es ist quasi so, es gibt dieses Problem schon seit länger und alle haben gesagt, ach komm, das wird nie passieren. Und jetzt ist es soweit, dass mal jemand das nachgebaut hat. Und wenn diese Leute das nachgebaut haben, heißt das, die können das jetzt? Oder heißt das, dass alle anderen, die ungefähr Gruppenplan von der Materie haben, können das auch nachmachen?
Also das Paper dazu und auch der POG, der war kurz... Der Proof of Concept.
Das heißt also, der hat dir mal ein Programm beschrieben, das beweist, dass ein theoretisches Problem auch tatsächlich in der Praxis existiert?
Genau, und der ist aber insofern nicht öffentlich, als dass in ein paar Leuten das gesehen haben, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass der irgendwie schon großartig posiert. Aber wird in den nächsten Tagen noch mal veröffentlicht.
Im Zweifel haben wir das in Zukunft alle. Man hat ja auch irgendwie... Was gab es letztens so Virenbaukästen für einen Zehner? Der sogenannte Aldi-Bot habe ich gelesen, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Möglicherweise taucht diese Lücke da auch irgendwann auf. Bevor wir jetzt dazu kommen, diese einzelnen Probleme in ihrer ganzen Komplexität annähernd anzureißen, sage ich jetzt mal, um nicht zu viel zu versprechen, würde ich gerne für alle, die jetzt zum ersten Mal einen tieferen Blick in diese Eingeweide des verschlüsselten Datenverkehrs nehmen wollen, erklären, was passiert denn eigentlich jetzt genau. Dieses Ding hat, wie gesagt, jeder schon mal gesehen. HTTPS, Doppelpunkt, Flash, deine Bank, irgendwas, keine Ahnung. Da wird eine Verbindung verschüsselt. Was heißt das? Was passiert da? Vielleicht erstmal ganz bei Null angefangen. Das Internet ist ja wie gesagt nochmal diese Postkartenmetapher. Da reichen sich Computer-Postkarten weiter. Und da können wir jetzt einfach keinen Briefumschlag draus machen, weil jeder Computer muss da sozusagen wissen, was er transferieren soll. Und dafür gibt es halt die Verschlüsselung. Dass man sagt, da steht eigentlich erstmal Kauderwelsch drin und die Computer auf dem Weg können damit alle nichts anfangen, außer der Empfänger. Und der Empfänger weiß mit einem gewissen Schlüssel, wie er aus dem Kauderwelsch wieder einen Sinn bekommt, der da sozusagen abgeschickt wurde. Okay, also mein Computer, sein Computer sagt, so Alter, ab jetzt verschlüsselt. Was passiert dann?
Ja, dann denken wir uns erstmal Schlüssel aus.
Früher hat man im Alphabet Buchstaben verschoben, um eine gewisse Anzahl oder so. Und dieser Schlüssel muss zwischen uns beiden ausgetauscht werden. Und dadurch, dass unsere beiden Computer erstmal darauf setzen, dass es wirklich der andere Computer von dir ist, mit dem Meiner reden will, haben wir da schon ein Problem, dass das nicht unbedingt gegeben sein muss. Also wenn wir hier im Studio sitzen, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit noch ein bisschen höher.
Aber sobald halt so eine Stadt oder ein Land dazwischen liegt, woher weiß mein Computer überhaupt, dass er mit dahinspricht.
Können wir es noch eine Ebene weiter nach unten gehen? Es gibt ja irgendwie das Prinzip der Verschüsselung zum Datenaustausch. Das ist hier auch asymmetrische Verschüsselung, oder ist das das passende Stichwort? Für alle, die nicht wissen, was das ist, könnte das kurzum reißen? Also wie dieser Vorstand, wie dieser Vorgang zu starten kommt? Oh Gott, entsetzte Gesichter. Nein, wer soll das denn jetzt erklären? Vor allem so, dass man es versteht. Okay, du fängst einfach an und ich unterbrech dich, wenn es zu schlimm wird. Ach, apropos unterbrechen. Das könnt ihr auch jederzeit tun, wenn ihr wollt. Denn heute ist der Plan wirklich, wir möchten, dass ihr versteht, wie dieses ganze Zeug funktioniert. Nicht bis ins letzte Detail, aber wenigstens grob das Konzept. Und wenn ihr da zu Fragen habt... Jetzt, hallo! 0331 70 97 110 So, also der Computer kommt zu dem anderen Computer und sagt, so Alter verschlüsselt kommunizieren. Genau, das ist der erste Schritt. Aha, was passiert dann? Jetzt muss ich gerade noch mal SSL machen. Genau, da gibt es einen öffentlichen Schlüssel, der ist bekannt vom Server. Also Schlüssel heißt in dem Zusammenhang immer eine Zeichenkette.
Eine Zeichenkette, genau.
Die ist, wenn möglich, sehr, sehr zufällig.
Diesen Schlüssel holt sich dann mal in den Browser und fängt dann an, die Daten, die er dem Server schicken möchte, zu verschlüsseln.
In dieser Zeichenkette. Wo kriegt er diesen Schlüssel her? Den kriegt er vom Server. Da steht in der Datei, das ist ein Zertifikat. Da steht dieser Schlüssel drinnen. Das ist der erste Punkt, wo man sagen muss, der kriegt von dem Server diese Zeichenkette und weiß also, wenn ich die damit verschlüssel, dann kann nur dieser Server die Daten lesen, die ich ihm schicke. Das ist der Plan dahinter, genau. Das ist der Plan. Wir kommen zu dem Problem dann später. Das ist der Plan, okay.
Das ist der Plan. Dann verschlüsselt der Browser diese Daten und schickt diese verschlüsselten Daten an den Server zusammen mit seinem Schlüssel.
Also mein Computer sagt dann dem Computer auf dem Server, okay Alter, das ist übrigens der Schlüssel, mit dem du verschlüsseln willst, wenn du nur mit mir redest. Der Server kann diese verschlüsselten Daten entschlüsseln, weil das ist ja sein öffentlicher Schlüssel gewesen. Okay, das ist also, ich möchte nochmal kurz sagen, dass dieses asymmetrische Verschlüsselungssystem, das ist halt der Befehl Mathematik. Genau. Das zu erklären, würde jetzt wahrscheinlich mindestens mir den Kopf platzen lassen und vermute vielleicht einem von euch auch. Aber es ist sozusagen so, es gibt zwei verschiedene, also man kann sich vorstellen, wie ein Schlüssel, mit dem man auf und mit dem man zuschließt. Das ist also nicht derselbe, sondern unterschiedlich.
Und diese Schlüssel werden halt ausgetauscht in der Kommunikation.
Und so kann jeder seine Pakete, also seine Informationen, selbstständig entschlüsseln. Und weiß halt dann, der Server schickt mir Daten zurück, ich kann die entschlüsseln und weiß dann, das ist für mich und das ist von dem Server und das ist eigentlich sicher. Okay, sind das tatsächlich sozusagen nur zwei Schritte? Also ich sage dem Server, ich nehme den öffentlichen Schlüssel, schicke damit verschlüsselte Daten im Server, sage dem, pass mal auf, das ist mein öffentlicher Schlüssel, dann der zurück und dann ist schon die verschlüsselte Kommunikation. Mehr ist dann nicht.
Um ein Verschlüssel da hinzustellen. Weil das eigentlich Spannende ist ja, dass man ganz am Anfang, wenn man den Schlüssel des anderen noch nicht kennt, ja trotzdem kommunizieren können muss und auch schon vertraulich. Und dort gibt es halt eine Methode, die nennt sich Divi-Helmen. Und die ist sozusagen für die initiale Kommunikation. Und ab dann wird irgendwann über die Keys kommuniziert.
Also wie findet denn dieser Kanal, Händeschlag oder wie kann man das nennen?
Es gibt halt einen SSL-Handshake, der in was mehreren Phasen besteht, wo sich Server und Client einigen, wer wie welche Daten verschlüsselt. Weil es gibt ja sozusagen zwei Wege, man kann sozusagen den Server, also dass man mit Serverzertifikat arbeitet oder mit Clientzertifikat. Also man kann das in zwei Richtungen machen. Wobei wir uns in der Regel tatsächlich nur um die Serverzertifikate kümmern, in dem Sinne, weil das ist eine Sache mit den Clientzertifikaten, da geht es eher um Businessanwendungen, wo ich sagen will, und das ist nämlich der andere Punkt der SSL auch macht, dass man sagen kann, wer sein Gegenüber ist. Also wir haben sozusagen nicht nur die Verschlüsselung, die sozusagen gegen das Mitlauschen im Netz schützen soll, sondern noch ein zweites Feature, nämlich, dass der Server mir beweisen kann, wer er ist.
Das klassische Beispiel ist ja immer Onlinebanking, deshalb ist ja genau beides wichtig. Also A will ich nicht, dass man die Information irgendwie mal mitliest, und B will ich natürlich, dass die Informationen nicht losgelegt, tatsächlich nur von meiner Bank gelesen werden.
Genau, und dass ich sagen kann, ja, das ist meine Bank.
Wie wird das dann nachgewiesen?
Jetzt kommen wir zum Punkt, den wir eigentlich viel später besprechen wollten.
Also pass auf, das später besprechen, auch für alle, die von der Neuheit gerufen sind, das später besprechen ist das der Problem. Wir diskutieren jetzt erstmal den Idealfall, wie es funktionieren sollte.
Also im allerbesten Fall sollte es so funktionieren, dass ich, wenn ich Online-Banking einrichte, eigentlich von meiner Bank zum Beispiel einen Brief bekomme, in dem der Fingerprint, also sprich so eine Zahl, die mir beweist, dass mein Gegenüber der Server ist, der er vorgibt zu sein.
Du musst kurz erklären, was ein Fingerprint ist.
Ein Fingerprint heißt, das ist halt so eine Zahl, eine Prüfsumme, die auch nicht leicht zu fälschen ist und die mir sagen kann, ich erwarte sozusagen diese Zeichenkette, wenn ich auf die Seite komme.
Also da bin ich ja eben schon ein bisschen ausgestehen. Die Frage ist ja eben, können die beiden Computer sicher sein, dass es wirklich die sind, die wir jetzt hier miteinander sprechen lassen wollen und nicht einer in der Mitte sitzt. Und das ist eben, wenn die Schlüssel gleich bei dieser Verbindung mit ausgetauscht werden, ja, dann kann sich halt auch einer in die Mitte stellen und behaupten, ich wäre jetzt der Server, mit dem du sprechen willst von mir, kriegst du den Schlüssel und dann, so, da muss es eben genau ein Seitenkanal geben. Und Foukami hat jetzt eben dafür plädiert, dass wir von der Bank quasi den Schlüssel auf dem anderen Kanal, sei es per Brief, den ganzen Schlüssel abtippen, ist ein bisschen viel. Da ist halt diese Prüfsumme das Entscheidende, mit der ich den Fingerprint, die Prüfsumme, mit der ich sozusagen mal prüfen kann, ob der Schlüssel, den ich von meiner Bank habe, wirklich, also, ne, ich brauche eine andere Kommunikationskanal mit meiner Bank. Er möchte an dieser Stelle anmerken, dass ich noch nie einen Brief von meiner Bank bekommen habe, wo irgendeine Zahl drinsteht. Wie läuft es denn gerade jetzt? Genau, gerade läuft anders.
Hast du schon mal deine Bank angerufen und gefragt?
Ich habe das gemacht, aber das kann ich auch später erklären. Es läuft einfach so, dass man darauf zugreift und eigentlich dem vertraut. Also eigentlich haben wir da schon so einen Punkt, wo wir gar nicht genau prüfen, ob das der Server ist, mit wem wir eigentlich reden.
Eigentlich wollte ich jetzt darauf hinaus, dass ich jetzt einen Schlüssel bekomme von meiner Bank, sondern weiß ich jetzt noch nicht, ob er wirklich von meiner Bank abgeschickt wurde. Und dafür gibt es sozusagen einen zweiten Schlüsselsatz, nämlich diese RUT-CAs, das sind sozusagen Zertifikate, die in meinem Browser ausgeliefert werden. Da gibt es zum Beispiel dieses Diginotar, was jetzt pleite ging, da gibt es die Deutsche Telekom drin, da gibt es den Deutschen Bundestag drin. Die dürfen alle diese öffentlichen Schlüssel sozusagen, also die unterschreiben sie und sagen, jupp, mir wurde jemand vorstellig, der hat sich als Markus Richter ausgewiesen, hatte diesen Schlüssel präsentiert. Und ich sage hier, Kraft meiner Amtes als Deutsche Telekom, jupp, so habe ich das gesehen und habe als Deutsche Telekom ein Zertifikat in jedem Browser, was sozusagen diese Unterschrift von mir überprüfen kann.
Genau, und jetzt gibt es im Browser die Möglichkeit zu gucken, wer hat welches Zertifikat unterschrieben. Das kann man halt genau nachvollziehen, also das steht halt drin, dass mit dem und dem RUT-Zertifikat wurde ein anderes Zertifikat signiert. Und man hat dann halt so mehrere, also in den meisten Fällen ist das so, halt mehrere Zertifikate, die aufeinander basieren, also eine Vertrauenskette.
Okay, also ich kriege das Zertifikat von, sagen wir ruhig, bleiben wir dabei im Beispiel, ich kriege ein Zertifikat von meiner Bank oder einen Schlüssel, sagen wir. Diese Zeichenkette ist wiederum schon verschlüsselt und auch signiert, nee nur signiert, von einem anderen Typen. Und im Lieferzustand meines Computers, sage ich mal, oder im Lieferzustand der Software, ist bereits enthalten, dass die Software weiß, okay, wenn folgendes Ding eintritt, was signiert ist, also wie der sozusagen durch so eine Verschlüsselung irgendwie überprüft, dann kannst du dem vertrauen.
Genau, also wenn man mal in den Browser guckt oder zum Beispiel in, also bei den Necks in den Keychains, dann sieht man halt eine ganze Latte an CAs. Ich habe das gerade mal aufgemacht.
Was heißt ein CA, kann man das genauer?
Certification Authority heißt das.
Eine berechtigte Ausstellungsstelle für Zertifikate. Ich habe die mal aufgemacht, auf meinem Mac, und da haben wir so Sachen drinne wie eine Firma, die heißt AC Raith Serti Kamara SA. Keine Ahnung, wo die herkommt. Aber erstmal vertraut jetzt meinen Browser dieser CA.
Dein ganzes Betriebssystem in dem Fall.
Ja, mein ganzes Betriebssystem sogar.
Dann habe ich hier einmal Belgium Root CA.
Das wird irgendwas Belgisches sein, vermutlich.
Dann habe ich hier noch so lustiges rumstehen. Dann hat es hier verschiedene Regierungen drinne.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich viele. Swiss Telekom.
Das haben wir hier drinne.
Also Swisscom ist das. Wir haben TurkTrust. Du sagst für Türkei. Visa macht das auch. Visa als Cleancard-Unternehmen, die machen nämlich ihr Zertifikat selbst. Und auch für andere. Es gibt also jede Menge Firmen, die diese Zertifikate ausstellen, die wiederum andere Zertifikate durchschreiben, denen wir dann vertrauen. Und wer legt denn fest, an welcher Stelle wird festgelegt, welche dieser Zertifikate, die mir vertrauen, wie die auf meinen Rechner kommen. Wie kommen die denn dahin? Das entscheidet der Softwarehersteller. Bei einem Mac-Rechner ist es Apple, bei einem Firefox ist es Mozilla, bei einem IntelliExplorer ist es Microsoft. Sie entscheiden, ich vertraue diesen Stellen. Deswegen vertraut mein User denen auch. Das heißt, wenn ich meinen Browser runterlade, nehme ich billigend in Kauf, dass ich genau all denen vertraue, wo der Hersteller des Browsers gesagt hat, das sind coole Jungs, die dürfen sagen, ob die Zertifikate toll sind. Das kannst du abstellen, aber erstmal ist das so. Also sagen wir im normalen Auslieferungszustand, also der, den alle Menschen benutzen, außer die Leute, die sich die Mühe machen. Na ja, ihr wisst schon Bescheid. Okay, die machen das so. Die nächste Frage wäre dann...
Also man kann jetzt gleich erklären, wo der Fehler schon in der Art und Weise liegt, wie das eigentlich passiert. Weil prinzipiell jede von diesen CAs jede Domäne signieren können. Also es gibt keine Mechanismus, der mir sagt, welche CA für welche Domäne zuständig ist.
Ja, aber das ist doch egal, weil auf meinem Rechner sind ja nur CAs, denen ich vertraue, weil die coolen Leute, die den Browser gebaut haben, vertrauen. Nein. Wieso? Habt ihr doch gerade so erklärt. Ja, aber jetzt haben wir ja gehört, Diginotar wurde gehackt und da wurde ein Google-Zertifikat ausgestellt. Es gibt kein Google-Diginotar-Zertifikat. Aber eigentlich ist es von jemand anderem singlet worden.
Also man kann jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn man...
Also der Reihe nach sozusagen, ich gehe zu Google, mache eine verschlüsselte Verbindung auf und kriege normalerweise ein Zertifikat, das ist von Firma... Ausgestellt, vielen Dank. Und jetzt ist jemand bei Diginotar eingeritten. Das ist auch so eine Stelle, der normalerweise vertraut wurde, muss man in dieser Stelle sagen. Und hat gesagt, okay, ich bin jetzt sozusagen der Besitzer von Diginotar, also zumindest virtuell, aber so geht das halt, und stelle also ein weiteres Zertifikat für Google aus.
Genau. So und da diese Zertifizierungsstelle in dem Browser als voll vertrauenswürdig markiert ist, kommt auch kein Fenster was hochpoppt und sagt, Achtung, hier ist irgendwas Fischi.
Dann hat also jemand ein Zertifikat für eine Webseite ausgestellt, auf der ich surfe. Also nicht nur für eine Webseite, sondern für alle Google-Subdomains und Google selbst.
Mal davon abgesehen, also was er jetzt kann, er kann dort dafür sorgen, dass er meinen Trafik entschlüsseln kann und wieder sozusagen neu verschlüsseln und sozusagen setzt sich zwischen mich und den Server.
Aber es reicht aber nicht, dass er nur diese Zertifikat irgendwie sozusagen sich aushält, er muss dann noch mehr machen, oder? Ja, ein Proxy halt.
Okay, also es gibt halt die Möglichkeit, dass man dort eben eine Möglichkeit schafft, einen Dienst zu haben, der, also Transparenz ist unsichtbar für mich als Nutzer, dafür sorgt, dass er entschlüsselt und das wieder neu verschlüsselt. Und sozusagen die Kommunikation zwischen ihm und mir kann er mitlesen. Und auch die Kommunikation zwischen dem Server und ihm kann er mitlesen. Und er vermittelt halt zwischen uns beiden sozusagen.
Okay, und normalerweise würde das auffallen, weil das Zertifikat falsch signiert ist. Aber in dem Fall, wo er sozusagen so einen Zertifikatsaussteller gehackt hat, denkt man Rechner dann so, alter geil, Diginotar, das Zertifikat zertifiziert. Gottes Willen. Und deswegen ist alles cool. Wie sind sie denn bei Diginotar überhaupt da reingekommen? Also was zur Hölle ist denn da genau passiert?
Das weiß ich eigentlich echt nicht.
Das schreiben sie sich aus steil.
Also da drüber wurde sich ausgeschwiegen.
Aber das Interessante ist halt, erst war natürlich die These, dass sie sozusagen das schon willentlich ausgestellt hatten für irgendeine andere Stelle. Und dann haben sie halt die Karte gezogen zu sagen, hey, wir wurden gehackt, was ja im Prinzip... Also die Verschwörungstheorie ist sozusagen, die haben das ausgehält für jemanden, der gerne Schindluder treiben wollte. Und die Pressemitteilung ist halt, wir wurden gehackt und damit kann der Laden dicht machen. Weil diese ganzen Zertifizierungsautoritäten sind halt wie Treuhänder, leben nur davon, dass sie einen guten Ruf haben, nämlich, dass sie keine Scheiße bauen. Und sobald sie einmal an der Stelle irgendwo Scheiße bauen, gibt es eigentlich keinen Grund mehr, die weiter zu nutzen. Also ich meine, wir haben ja da ein paar Hundert. Also ich meine es ja nicht so, dass... Dann taucht die offensichtliche Frage, auf die Robin stellen möchte. Hallo Robin.
Ja, hallo, guten Abend.
Und deine Frage ist nämlich genau welche?
Meine Frage ist, es kam jetzt gerade mal so von wegen, ja, jeder Browser hat eine Liste von vertrauenswürdigen Certification-Autorities. Und meine Frage ist eigentlich, wie entscheiden denn die Programmierer von den Browsern, welche jetzt eigentlich, welche von den Serves jetzt eigentlich vertrauenswürdig ist? Also müssen die im Idealfall irgendwie eine Datenbank haben, zehn Meter unter der Erde, am besten noch ein Vier mit Stahlbeton oben drüber und doppelt und dreifach gesichert, oder wie läuft das? Also jeder, der die Zertifikate in seine Software mit einbaut, also eben Browser-Hersteller und Betriebssystem-Hersteller, haben einen gewissen Auditprozess. Das heißt, sie werden eben bestimmte Dinge voraussetzen, damit diese Zertifikate dort drin sind. Also das heißt, entweder, weil sie halt irgendwie einen bestimmten Prozess haben, wo sie sagen, wir können damit halt absichern, wie das irgendwie ist, oder sind selber Zertifikatshersteller.
Okay, andersrum gefragt zu sagen, ich bin jetzt Zertifikatshersteller und komme zu euch und sage, ihr Browser-Hersteller, ich habe ihr voll das geile Zertifikat, nehmt es mal bitte mit auf. Was fragt ihr mich dann? Dann frage ich dich erstmal, wie du dein System absicherst, wie du den Registrierungsprozess machst, also dass ich ein Zertifikat bekomme bei dir und auch wie sicher ist dein System, also kann da jemand eindringen einfach so und das wird dann geordertet, ganz regulär. Also quasi sagen, Fachleute unterhalten sich darüber und müssen, der Zertifikatsausteller muss es schaffen, den Hersteller davon zu überzeugen, okay, wir sind cool.
Ich meine, wir haben lange Jahre im Firefox die chinesischen Start als CA-Stelle drin gehabt.
Also das ist... Also Robin, verstehst du deine Frage auch so, ob du wissen möchtest oder es gerne hättest, dass es irgendwo noch eine weitere Quelle gibt, wo man mal nachgucken könnte, welche Zertifikate jetzt gut sind und welche nicht? Gibt's da? Also es gibt ja manchmal so sagen, kümmern sich Leute noch darum, dass sie noch mal extra nachgucken. Also wir müssen jetzt vertrauen, dass das, was auf unserem Rechner herumliegt, stimmt. Jetzt kann man sich irgendwie von Hand hinsetzen, also nachgucken, sind die jetzt noch irgendwie gut, aber es will man nicht. Gibt's noch irgendwelche Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen, Zertifikatestellen noch mal extra unabhängig? Ich will jetzt nicht TÜV sagen, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine? Ja, es gibt Menschen, die darüber nachdenken zumindest, da was zu tun, aber es ist halt unglaublich schwer, weil du hast diese CA-Stelle, die Zertifikate signiert, und du kannst es nicht nochmal nachsignieren, das geht natürlich nicht. Du kannst jetzt natürlich nur sagen, ok, hier ist Shinto passiert, und immer erst dann, wenn was passiert ist, werden die Browserhersteller anfangen, die CAS rauszunehmen, wie jetzt auch bei Diginotar passiert ist.
In der neuen Firefox-Version ist es raus. Apple hat angekündigt, beim nächsten Update ist es auch raus.
Momentan muss man es noch mit der Hand entfernen. Das ist also mehr so, als wenn irgendwas passiert ist, dann fliegen die Leute raus. Es gibt keine Kontrollbörder, also ich meine jetzt nicht, dass automatisch dann noch mal signiert wird, wo man auf der Webseite vielleicht nachgucken könnte oder sowas. Es muss ja erstmal was passiert sein, damit man überhaupt einen Grund hat, noch mal nachzuschauen. Ich dachte auch gerade, weil ihr meintet, da steht der chinesische Staat drin, und dann stehen da halt möglicherweise dubiose Firmen drin. Könnte da nicht mal einer einen Blog aufmachen, wo man sowas nachlesen kann? Das finde ich tatsächlich ein spannendes Ding. Ja, weil jemand ist leider zusammengebrochen, das ist die nächsten zehn Tage nicht verfügbar.
Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass Diginotar die erste Firma ist, das ist schon öfter passiert. Es gab halt Staat, TLS, Komodo, es sind also einige von diesen Herstellern, die auch schon Sicherheitsschwankungen hatten, die dafür gesorgt haben, dass die Zertifikate halt irgendwie informativ wurden.
Robin, ich vermute, die Antwort auf deine Frage ist, wissen wir auch nicht so genau, gibt es im Moment noch nicht.
Okay, noch eine Frage und...
Warte, warte, warte, warte. Es ist jetzt halb elf, ich muss dich deswegen wieder zurück in die Warteschleife stellen. Wir machen ein ganz kurzes Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Datenverkehr. Danach geht es hier weiter im Chaos Radio. Und wir machen weiter mit dem Datenverkehr. Der Vorsitzende der CDU-Bundestagsfraktion, Friedrich Kauder, möchte sich selbst den Internetzugang abstellen. Seinem Vorschlag zufolge sollten Leuten, die online ein Urheberrechtsdelikt begangen haben, sofort der Zugang zum Internet verboten werden. Bekannterweise hat Kauder selbst auf seiner eigenen Website Fotos des Bilderdienst Panoramio übernommen, ohne die dazu notwendige Zustimmung einzuholen. Vergangenen Nacht sind einige Bilder von seiner Seite verschwunden. Kauder sagte heute dazu, die Fotos sind entfernt also, das Warnmodell funktioniert. Die EU-Kommission fordert mehr Einfluss von Regierungen auf Internetinfrastrukturen. Auf dem Internet Governance Forum in Nairobi forderte Nili Kroos erneut, dass die sogenannte Internetverwaltung ICAN besser mit Regierungen zusammenarbeiten soll. Die ICAN ist zuständig für Namens- und Adressräume und hatte zuvor die Domainendung XXX für Rotlichtinhalte beschlossen. Microsoft hat mit Samsung einen Patentdeal abgeschlossen, ähnlich wie mit HTC schon vor einem Jahr. Endlich kann der Riese aus Redmond an den Verkäufen der beiden größten Android-Telefonhersteller in den USA mitverdienen. Um welche Teile es Microsoftschen Patentportfolio es sich handelt, ist zur Stunde noch unklar. Philipp Börger mit dem Datenverkehr, vielen Dank!
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de fritz.de Und das Auge hört mit, man.
Heute Chaos Radio, mein Name ist Markus Richter und das Studio ist wieder voll mit Leuten, die chaotisch sind beziehungsweise vom Chaos Computer Club. Das kleine Wortspiel-Seminar in dieser Stelle noch ein einziges Mal erlaubt. Herzlich willkommen zurück, Herr Obach, auch bekannt als die Tomate. Du musst was sagen. Man hört dich im Radio sonst nicht, wenn du nichts sagst. Das ist echt schwierig.
Da bin ich wieder.
Sieht gut aus wie immer. Herr Foukami.
Hallo.
Und Herr Wetterfrosch. Die drei sind hier angetreten, um herauszustellen, was mit dem...
Ich würde mal kurz was sagen zu den Meldungen, die wir gehört haben. Da wurde von Friedrich Kauder gesprochen, das ist natürlich Siegfried. Aber es gibt noch so eine Sache, die besonders lustig ist. Und zwar, wenn man die Erklärung von Kauder liest, gibt es da einen denkwürdigen Satz drin. Und zwar, ich zitiere, ich bitte zur Kenntnis zu nehmen, dass die U-Heber-Rechte an den beiden Fotos inzwischen mir zustehen. Wer sich ein bisschen mit U-Heber-Rechten auskennt, der wird verstehen, dass in Deutschland die Übertragung von U-Heber-Rechten nicht möglich ist, sondern nur von Nutzungsrechten.
Entschuldigung, wenn der Herr Kauder das so gesagt hat, dann wird das schon stimmen. Er ist Politiker und hat also Ahnung vom Thema. Klar. Gut, hätten wir das auch geklärt. Wer hat eigentlich diese Meldung geschrieben? Ich meine, das mit dem Siegfried und dem Volker, das ging doch schon vor drei Wochen. Ha, der hat da so einen Bruder, der ist auch in diesem Parlament. Wir sprechen heute auch eigentlich über SSL, über verschlüsselte Internetverbindungen, haben in der ersten halben Stunde schon versucht, euch noch einmal das grundlegende Konzept hinter der Datenverschlüsselung beim Webbrowsing zu erklären. Das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, wir haben diese halbe Stunde auch wirklich gebraucht. Alles, was ich jetzt noch sagen kann, ist, in diesem ganzen Vorgang gibt es eine Stelle, wo es wichtig ist, dass eine bestimmte externe Firma sagt, geil, diesem Datendienst, den du gerade ansprichst, dem kannst du vertrauen. Und so eine Firma ist gehackt worden und das ist ein bisschen problematisch gewesen. Wir hatten jetzt Robin am Telefon, der wollte wissen, ob es irgendwo so eine Art Seite gibt, wo man nachgucken kann, welche sind jetzt noch vertrauenswürdig und welche dieser Anbieter wurden gehackt. Die Antwort ist, gibt es nicht. Dann hatte Robin noch eine Frage. Willkommen zurück Robin, sag mal.
Ja, meine andere Frage, die ich noch hatte und zwar, jetzt wurde ja schon gesagt, jetzt wurde vor ein paar Wochen die Diginotar gehackt, diese Zertifizierung, oder eine von diesen Zertifizierungsstellen. Und die haben jetzt, diese Hacker haben ein Google-Zertifikat bei denen ausgestellt, obwohl Google selbst eigentlich seine Zertifikate von anderen Zertifizierungsstellen ausstellen lässt. Gibt es denn nicht irgendwie eine Möglichkeit, dass man quasi eine Datenbank macht, dass man zum Beispiel sagt, Google stellt nur bei der und der Zertifizierungsstelle Zertifikate aus, sodass wenn jetzt quasi jemand anders zu einer verzaubernden Zertifizierungsstelle gehen würde, um da was auszustellen, dass das dann quasi trotzdem nicht gültig wäre, weil es eben nicht mit der Zertifizierungsstelle übereinstimmt, wo jetzt zum Beispiel Google normalerweise hingeht und seine Zertifizierungsstellen lässt.
Also im Prinzip zu sagen, so eine Art, okay, es gibt zwar beliebig viele Firmen, die theoretisch alles unterschreiben dürfen, aber man konnte ja irgendwo nachschlagen, wer eigentlich normalerweise dafür zuständig ist. Der Herr Urbach hat die ganze Zeit während er das gesagt hat, wie er total wild auf seinem Stuhl rumgehandelt. Herr Urbach, was zur Hölle ist los? Ja, das ist eine Idee, die die Leute seit irgendwie zehn Jahren haben. Und nein, funktioniert nicht. Weil? Denn jetzt, also nehmen wir an, ich bin jetzt Google und ich habe irgendwie ganz viele Rechenzentren. Und ich habe ja schon pro Rechenzentrum jeweils ein neues Zertifikat für jeden Dienst. Einfach aus Sicherheitsgründen. So, jetzt kaufe ich mir einfach, ich brauche 20 neue Zertifikate und gehe mir die einkaufen, und zwar da, wo sie vielleicht am günstigsten sind.
Und ich trage das nicht in dieser Datenbank nach.
Dann sind es gültige Zertifikate, und werde aber in dieser Datenbank als nö, kennen wir nicht dargestellt. Also das ist tabselig.
Na ja, doch, es gibt einen Hack. Also und zwar gibt es einen Hack, den zum Beispiel Chrome einsetzt. Und zwar nennt sich dieser Trick harte TPS-Pinning beziehungsweise Public Key Pinning. Und zwar ist die Idee dahinter, dass Google natürlich, wenn es selber Software herstellt und dort bei dem Browser eben die Zertifikate reintun kann, ja schon sagen kann, dass die Domäne Google com von einer ganz bestimmten CA signiert sein muss. Und das funktioniert halt für Betriebssystemen und einer Browser-Hersteller, die selber das liefern, natürlich hervorragend. Also das wird wahrscheinlich aber Standard sein bei den anderen.
Das funktioniert aber sozusagen immer nur für die eigene Domain dann.
Google wird sicherlich auch noch eine ganze Reihe an anderen Sachen da reintun, an anderen Domains, die irgendwie wichtig sind. Also auch sozusagen andere Domains, die ihnen gehören, aber vielleicht eben auch andere Domains, die halt aus irgendeinem anderen Grunde Wichtigkeit sind. Aber es eskaliert halt nicht.
Ja aber ich wollte gerade sagen, ist das nicht sozusagen so ein Henne-Eil-Problem? Also wenn man sagt, wenn sich jetzt alle darauf einigen würden, okay ihr könnt euch gerne neue Zertifikatur kaufen, wo ihr wollt, wie akzeptieren sie aber erst, wenn sie sich auch dort bei dieser Stelle gemeldet haben?
Also das funktioniert wiederum nicht. Also wie gesagt, man hat ein Skalierungsproblem, als dieses System von CAs und so weiter entstanden ist, da gab es halt ein paar tausend Rechner und da konnte man diese Art von Modell, die man jetzt hat, noch relativ gut machen, weil es überschaubar war. Das ist natürlich bei einer Milliarde Seiten nicht mehr ohne Weiteres möglich, diese Listen zu pflegen.
Würde ich ja denken, jetzt wird es doch alles automatisierbar. Wozu haben wir die ganzen schnellen Rechner und das Gigabit-Netz? Ich habe über dieses Twitter einen Einwurf bekommen, Certificate Patrol für Firefox, dieses Gigabit-Netz.
Ja, das Thema haben wir nachher für die Lösung.
Genau. Okay Robin, dann möchte ich an dieser Stelle sagen, es gibt keine wirkliche Lösung für dein Problem, aber möglicherweise einen kleinen Hack, den wir später noch genauer erläutern. So, jetzt haben wir hier noch den Carsten am Telefon. Und der Carsten hat eine Frage an die geneigten Damen und Herren vom Chaos Computer Club, die auch ein Wiki zu dieser Sendung betreiben. Hallo Carsten.
Wunderschön, guten Abend.
Was ist denn da deine Frage?
Ja, die Leitung war gerade ein bisschen wackelig.
Ja, folgendes.
Ihr habt ein Wiki zum Chaos Radio und ich als Autonomalverbraucher surfe da drauf und bekomme die schöne Meldung, dass die Sicherheit nicht gewährleistet werden könnte, weil das Zertifikat nicht vertrauenswürdig wäre.
Da ist jetzt die Frage, welche Ursache das genau hat. Entweder ist es ein abgelaufenes Zertifikat, das hatte ich vorhin gehört für Chaos Radio CCC. Das wäre in der Tat nicht schön. Zertifikate gibt man immer eine Gültigkeitsdauer und dann frischt man die wieder auf, falls da mal was passiert mit. Allerdings haben wir in der Regel bei CCC-Inhalten ein selbstsigniertes Zertifikat immer an Start, weil wir sagen, dieses ganze System, SSL, wie es läuft mit irgendwie, wir haben ja schon ein paar Organisationen genannt, die da unterschreiben dürfen, das finden wir als solches nicht wirklich traghaft. Deshalb sagen wir, ja wir zertifizieren uns selber. Und dann kriegste einmal einen Schlüssel, klar, dann kannst du nicht wirklich überprüfen, ob der von uns kam, aber du kannst den zumindest speichern und dann merken, wenn er geändert wird. Ja, aber ist das dich irgendwie ein bisschen doppelt?
Also in diesem speziellen Fall ist das Problem, dass das Zertifikat abgelaufen ist und zwar am 13. Diginotar waren sie vielleicht günstiger, aber nicht so gut gesichert. Es gibt auch das Zertifikat, was zum Beispiel oder die CA, die die Seite Chaosradio CCDE benutzt, die ist von CA-SERD, das ist halt sozusagen eine ja Community-Lösung. Das ist zwar prinzipiell, hat das auch so ein bisschen Probleme mit Vertrauen und so weiter, aber da ist es halt so, dieses Zertifikat ist ja nicht im Browser drinne, das heißt, da poppt das beim ersten Mal auf und sagt hier, wir haben da kein Hut-Zertifikat zu. Und wenn ich das dann das erste Mal, wenn ich ihm halt vertraue oder wenn ich das halt mit rein packe, dann sind in Zukunft alle Zertifikate, die mit diesem, ist das aber mit zweierlei Maß gemessen.
Die meisten Leute klicken wahrscheinlich einfach so, ja klar vertraue ich und dann, das ist der Punkt, wo man eigentlich noch mal hätte genauer nachhaken müssen.
Das wollte ich jetzt auch gerade sagen. Also ich meine, das kann natürlich jede Webseite einfach sagen, ich verteile hier Zertifikate und der User sagt, ja ja, ist mir doch egal. Ich denke da vor allem an den Internet Explorer User und der sagt dann einfach, ja ich nehme das schon an, Sicherheitsausnahme ist mir doch egal, macht doch einfach, natürlich auch so ein bisschen schwierig dann. Also die Frage ist ja, was du eigentlich möchtest damit. Wenn du irgendwie haltet DPS benutzt, aus dem Grund, weil du vermeiden willst, dass jemand, der im selben Netzwerk ist, Mitglied ist, also zum Beispiel wenn du irgendwie über WLAN im Netz bist, also keine Ahnung, irgendwie im Internetcafé oder in der Uni, dann ist es im Prinzip ja vollkommen egal, ob da so ein Fenster aufpoppt oder nicht, weil da geht es nur darum, dass verschlüsselt ist.
Naja, aber in dem Moment, wo ich dieses Fenster aufpoppe und es bestätige, ist es möglicherweise an einem selben Netzwerk gewesen, gerade wenn man in das Mittel spielt.
Ja, das kann passieren, aber ich habe ja die Meldung, die sagt mir, was dort eben der Fehler ist. Wenn der Fehler so ist, dass ich ihn verstehe und sagen kann, okay, ich verstehe, warum jetzt dieses Fenster aufpoppt und ich verstehe, es ist aus dem Grund, weil dieses RU-Zertifikat nicht in meinem Browser ist, dann ist das okay. Also dann muss das nicht zwangsläufig ein Angriff sein. Problematisch wird es...
Naja, muss nicht zwangsläufig sein, aber du kannst auch an der Stelle nicht nachweisen, dass es keiner ist, oder?
Ja, das kannst du aber, wenn kein Fenster aufpoppt, auch nicht sagen.
Man braucht immer diesen Seitenkern eigentlich, also das, was diese Zertifizierungsstellen probieren auszugleichen, was halt so dubios funktioniert, aber ansonsten wäre eigentlich der klassische Fall wirklich auf ein anderem Medium. Also das ist so hochpflichtig anwendig mit deinem Computer, also mein Computer mit deinem Computer. Und da würde ich gerne noch einen einwerfen aus dem Chat. Die Sparkasse hat wohl in der Tat, die Berliner Sparkasse, ihre Fingerprints, diese Prüf-Sommen, von denen wir vorhin sprachen, mal per Post geschickt, als die sich geändert haben an ihre Leute. Also wussten natürlich wahrscheinlich die meisten der Empfänger auch nichts damit anzufangen, aber in der Tat... Oh nein, mein Kontostand hat Buchstaben in der Summe. Okay, also der Seitenkanal, da müssen wir ja nochmal genauer drüber sprechen, was ist und wie man das macht. Carsten, wenn dir eine zweite Frage zu haben geht, wie einfach ist es die eigene Webseite sozusagen über SSL erreichbar zu machen, dann kann ich nur sagen, ich hab das mehrfach schon im Genach geguckt, wenn man das einfach kaufen will, ohne sich selber da Finger anzulegen, es bewegt sich tatsächlich so in diesem hunderter Bereich für ein Jahr.
Ja, das geht ja wirklich, ne?
Naja, muss man sich auch leisten wollen, aber dann würde ich sagen, geht es. So, jetzt haben wir schon das eine, also wir hatten ja am Anfang drei Probleme. Das eine Problem war, da ist so ein Zertifikatsausteller gehackt worden, dann hatten wir irgendwie ein Land hat E-Mails abgehört und dann haben wir noch das seltsame BEAST, da kommen wir ganz am Schluss zu. Ich würde jetzt auf diese Stelle zu sprechen kommen, liebe Tomate, wo du gesagt hast, da hat irgendjemand, also ein Land hat da Dinge an den Start gebracht. Was zur Hölle ist da passiert? Ja, was zur Hölle ist passiert, eine Regierung hat sich entschieden, ihr gesamtes Volk abzuhören, komplett. Und hat dafür Infrastruktur eingekauft, also Geräte mit Software drauf, die das tun, was wir vorhin beschrieben haben, diese Man-of-the-Middle-Attacken. Es wurden gefälschte Zertifikate gekauft dafür, unter anderem auch bei Diginotar. Also was heißt gefällt? Gefällt heißt sozusagen, jemand ist bei einer anderen Firma eingedrungen, hat sozusagen ein echtes Zertifikat geholt, was er aber eigentlich nicht hätte ausstellen dürfen. Genau. In dem Fall also so gefälscht und damit wurde der gesamte Google-Traffic abgehört, also auch der ganze Google-Mail-Verkehr abgehört innerhalb des Landes natürlich nur. Und natürlich ist hier dann auch zurückverfolgen, wer hat diese Mail gerade geschrieben, wer surft da gerade auf vielleicht regimekritischen Seiten und da es eine Vollüberwachung ist des Netzes, auch der Telekommunikation komplett, leben so Menschen im Iran momentan noch gefährlicher als eh schon, auch in anderen Ländern, über die ich jetzt aber nicht sprechen werde, weil da noch Menschen dran arbeiten, das sicherer zu machen, die auch Technologie aus dem Iran bekommen haben mit Fachpersonal.
Übrigens, ist das alles deutsche Technik, die da im Einsatz ist? Ja, es ist auch, es ist nicht nur Siemens, es ist auch noch ein bisschen Cisco dabei.
Was heißt denn Technik? Also Netzwerktechnologie, wo Software draufläuft, die zum Beispiel von BlueCode ist, das ist ein, eigentlich ist das Software, um Firmenetzwerke sicher zu machen. Aber die kann man halt auch dazu benutzen? Man kann sie aber auch genau als andere benutzen. Ja, und das passiert genau gerade in Nordafrika. Und das ist natürlich ganz, ganz krass gefährlich, was da gerade passiert, weil einfach die Menschen, die davon ausgehen, weil wir ihnen jahrelang erzählt haben, man nutzt SSL, da wir unsere Ruhe hatten, das jetzt auch machen, aber es halt in dem Fall nicht sicher ist. Also in keiner Weise sicher. Ist das, wie sie sagen, das Nicht-Verhandensein, diese Sicherheit, ist das jetzt auch eine Ausprägung dieses Problems mit diesen Zertifikatsaustellern, die gehackt wurden oder ist das nochmal eine neue Dimension? Das ist einerseits einmal das Problem natürlich gehackte Zertifikatsausteller und so wurde das Google-Zertifikat gefälscht, aber auch, dass andere Dinge mit Zertifikaten passieren können, die ich jetzt leider auch im Radio nicht sagen kann, was genau das ist, aber es gibt Technologien, um Rohzertifikate sehr gut zu fälschen, das Browser sie als richtig anerkennen und somit Zertifikatsketten zu fälschen. Also da reden wir dann nicht mehr davon, dass irgendwo jemand bei einem Zertifikatsausteller einbricht und sich quasi ein echtes ausstellt, sondern dass man tatsächlich eine Fälschung anfertigt? Genau, solche Fälschungen, die ganze Zertifikatskette nachher falsch ist und somit auch abgehört werden kann. Aber wir haben ja am Anfang geklärt, dass das sozusagen derbe Mathematik ist, die hinter dieser ganzen Verschlüsselung beruht und das heißt, es gibt dann im Grunde genommen Algorithmus irgendein Problem oder woran liegt das, dass das geht? Das ist das Problem, das ist es noch nicht. Okay. Daran arbeiten gerade ganz viele Menschen überall auf der Welt, um genau das Problem zu lösen. Das heißt also, im Prinzip heißt das ja, SSL ist quasi im Arsch? Ne, die Zertifikate sind im Arsch, nicht SSL ist.
Also wir reden hier eigentlich über ein Vertrauen, das falsch rum funktioniert. Ich vertraue halt global Dinge, denen ich nicht vertrauen. So und diese Art von Vertrauen wird halt dem Problem, was ich eigentlich habe, eben auch nicht gerecht. Und ich kann in so einer verteilten Welt, wie wir leben, halt bestimmte Dinge auch einfach nicht lösen ohne Weiteres. Also das ist sozusagen ein ganz fundamentaler Punkt, der dort einfach nicht ordentlich funktionieren kann. Also ich müsste eigentlich mir andere Modelle überlegen, die mit Vertrauen zu tun haben. Also ein Modell ist halt zu sagen, also wie halt Web of Trust, also bei GPG. Also das heißt... Also ganz einfach.
Warte, warte, bevor wir zum Web of Trust kommen, was wir sagen, die Lösung eines Problems ist, dass wir das noch gar nicht vollständig beschrieben haben. Möchte ich das mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen und dann machen wir auch eine kurze Pause, um das sacken zu lassen. Es ist also so, dass diese Technologie der Verstößelung von Web Traffic darauf baut, dass ich an irgendeiner Stelle hingehe und sage so, weil ein Zertifikat auf einem Rechner ist, vertraue ich dir oder möglicherweise hat jemand anderes das geschrieben. Und du sagst, es ist ein grundlegendes Problem, dass man es so um eigentlich gar nicht machen kann.
Genau.
Dass man sozusagen eine andere Art und Weise haben müsste, wie man dazu kommt, dass am Anfang, wo diese Verbindung aufgebaut wird, die beiden Rechner gegeneinander irgendwie rausfinden können, ob sie wirklich der sind, den sie vorzugeben seien.
Das müsste man irgendwie lösen. Nur ganz kurz, gibt es dafür schon Lösungsvorschläge oder ist das so ein Problem, wo man dann in der Sackkasse steht und sagt, ok Leute, bis hierhin war es schick, aber wir kommen jetzt nicht weiter?
Ja und nein, es gibt Details, wo man bestimmte Sachen lösen kann und man kann auch mit viel Aufwand, wenn man das unbedingt haben will, kann man da Lösungen für bauen, aber für Otto Normal User ist das alles nicht wirklich benutzbar.
Ok, das ist ja immer so eigentlich.
Man fängt jetzt an eben bestimmte konzeptionellen Bugs und um Protokollschwächen drum herum zu hacken sozusagen. Also einfach da irgendwie so Workarounds zu bauen.
Ok, wir kommen dazu gleich, um noch mal diese einzelnen Bugs möglicherweise ein oder zwei anzugucken und zu sagen, was es ist. Vorher klären wir noch sozusagen das dritte große Problem, das sogenannte BEAST, was ich einen super Namen finde. Und bevor wir das machen, hören wir mal noch ein Song vom geneigten Professor Click, der Shifting-Focus heißt und dann sind wir gleich wieder da. Heute Chaosradio. Zu Gast sind zumindest theoretisch drei Leute. Momentan sieht es ein bisschen anders aus. Die haben sich während der Musik verkrümelt und machen jetzt keine Ahnung wilde Dinge. Vielleicht hacken sie unser Netzwerk oder so. Aber immerhin einer von den drei, nämlich der Foukami, ist noch hier. Hallo und willkommen zurück.
Hallo.
Wir wollten ja diese diese Kurzunterbrechung benutzen, um bevor wir auf das SSL und die verschüsselten Webkommunikationen wieder zu sprechen kommen, um damit ihr ein bisschen Platz habt, um zu erzählen, was der Club so in nächster Zeit anzustehen hat. Bitte schön.
Ja, also das erste ist die Party 30HCCC, die am Samstag stattfinden wird. Und zwar im Stadtbad Wedding. Das ist Gerichtstraße 65.
Wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Das ist richtig so?
Das wird richtig Party.
Also da kann man hingehen und Party feiern. Da muss man keinen Rechner mitbringen. Sagt es nicht so vielen Leuten?
Ja, wir hatten halt schon sonst, also vor zwei Wochen oder wann der Termin war, genau 12. September, da hatten wir halt so intern so ein bisschen in den verschiedenen Orten miteinander irgendwie geredet, über 30 Jahre und so weiter, und auch mit den alten Herren, mit den Bundeskandidaten.
Ich muss sogar lachen, weil ich dachte, man macht beim Geburtstag so Familien-Treffen, wo so Mutti und Vati und so einen Kuchen essen und Kaffee trinken, und dann macht man noch die Party.
Ja, weil das für die älteren Leute, die alle den Nester im Club.
Und vorher gibt es noch die Flummi Open, die erste Weltmeisterschaft im Flummi werfen. Was ist das eigentlich? Klar, aber wie misst man sich im Flummi werfen? Ich glaube, da gab es so verschiedenste Disziplinen, ich habe es mir kurz angeschaut, so mit Geschicklichkeit und irgendwie Präzision und Ziele treffen. Okay, verrücktes Backofenzeug.
Ich darf es eben noch auf einen zweiten Termin hinweisen. Wir haben ja immer jedes Jahr unseren Kongress und wir haben da einen sogenannten Call of Paper. Das heißt, dass wir dort halt... Hat er gerade Call of Duty gesagt? Dass wir dort halt Leute auffordern, uns Vorschläge für Vorträge einzusenden und die Vorschlagsfrist ist noch zwölf Tage bis zum 11.10.
Heißt das, also der Kongress ist immer zu Silvester? Das ist wahrscheinlich auch dieses Jahr wieder so, zwischen den Jahren, genau. Heißt das, ich habe noch zwölf Tage Zeit, Dinge einzureichen, über die ich einen Vortrag halten will? Oder heißt das auch, ich kenne einen Typen, der macht total geiles Zeug, schreibt den doch mal an?
Das geht schon beides.
Okay, alles klar. Also wenn ihr auch immerhin noch was habt, was ihr denkt, das sollt ihr auf dem Kongress unbedingt mal Gehör finden, dann könnt ihr das noch wohin eigentlich?
Auf der Webseite Events.CCCDE, da gibt es eine Seite, die heißt CFP for 28 Chaos Communication Congress. Das können wir vielleicht irgendwo einfach mal hinpacken. Also auf Events.CCCDE, da kann man das verlinkt und dann gibt es halt unseren PentaBuff. Das ist unser Submission System für Vorträge.
Das ist total sicher übrigens. Das ist eine andere Geschichte. Wir können jetzt mal zum eigentlichen Thema des Blue Moons zurückkommen. Und das ist hier im Chaos Radio die verschlüsselte Webkommunikation. Wir haben jetzt schon geklärt, wie die im groben Konzept funktioniert. Wir haben auch geklärt, dass es ein Problem damit gibt, dass unsere Rechner miteinander kommunizieren und das nicht nur direkt tun, sondern von der dritten Seite quasi ausgestellt kriegen. Und ja, was du machst, ist gerade super. Und wenn man diese Seite angreift, hat man eigentlich das ganze System in der Hand. Wir haben auch gerade von Herrn Urbach gehört, dass es ausgenutzt wurde, dass dieses System so angreifbar ist, weil der Iran tatsächlich irgendwie fast die ganze Webkommunikation einfach mal abgehört hat und damit alles mitkriegt, auch was halt angeblich verschlüsselt ist. Und jetzt habt ihr am Anfang der Sendung ja auch gesagt, es gibt noch jetzt sowas, das gerade im Umlauf ist. Das ist BEAST, also eine Sicherheitslücke für verschlüsselte Kommunikation, die schon seit Jahren existiert, wo jetzt aber zum ersten Mal das jemand sozusagen praktisch umgesetzt hat. Als ich davon gefragt habe, wer erklärt das von euch? Habt ihr alle große Augen bekommen und habt dann den Telefonjoker gezogen? Sehe ich das richtig? Der Telefonjoker ist heute Abend Andreas Brug.
Einen schönen guten Abend.
Einen schönen guten Abend. So BEAST, wir haben vorhin schon gehört, es ist eine Abkürzung 4.
Also ich muss dazu sagen, dass das ja noch nicht im Detail veröffentlicht ist. Das heißt, was existiert sind Andeutungen aus welchen Schwachstellen das beruht. Und ich kann mir ungefähr zusammenreinen, wie es funktioniert. Ich habe mit anderen Leuten darüber geredet, die auch sich mit Crypto aufkennen, die sind derselben Meinung. Ich könnte es noch nicht ganz programmieren, aber zumindest habe ich das grundlegende Prinzip, verstanden. Und zwar handelt es sich um einen Chosen Plantext-Attack, mit dem der Initialization Vector vorhergesagt werden kann durch das Erreichene von 6.5 CBC. Ja, schön.
Also das Nerd-Bullshit-Bingo geht heute ganz klar an Herrn Bogg. Vielen Dank dafür. Ich finde es ja super, dass normalerweise bin ich ja in der Sendung, der irgendwie so eher keinen Plan hat und nachfragt. Jetzt haben die anderen drei auch gerade alle so Augen bekommen.
Ich habe das schon verstanden.
Erklär doch mal. Und Andreas korrigiert.
Das geht schnell, wenn ich das erkläre.
Ich glaube auch, dass es schnell geht, wenn du es erklärst. Aber kannst du es so erklären, dass ich es auch verstehe?
Also, wir fangen mal ganz vorne an. Verschlüsselung. Es gibt zwei verschiedene Verschlüsselungsverfahren, wenn man Daten verschlüsseln will, sogenannte Stream-Cypher, wo Byte für Byte verschlüsselt wird, und sogenannte Block-Cypher, wo immer 8 oder 16 Byte auf einmal verschlüsselt werden. Üblicherweise für eine Verbindung per SSL oder TLS wird sowas wie AIS verwendet. Was ein Block-Cypher ist, mit 16 Byte Blockgröße.
Also ich will nur sagen, um es kurz noch ein bisschen klar zu machen, es geht um kleinere oder größere Datenmengen, die am Stück verschlüsselt werden. Genau. Und man nimmt da die größeren Datenmengen.
Und wenn man das jetzt so Blockweise macht, hat man das Problem, dass wenn du zweimal dasselbe verschlüsselst, immer dieselben 16 Byte rauskommen. Weil also dieselben 16 Byte werden immer zu den selben 16 Byte verschlüsselt. Das heißt, man sieht an dem Verschlüsselten, man kann Muster wieder erkennen. Deswegen wird erst etwas gemacht, das nennt sich Cypher-Block-Chaining. Da wird der letzte verschlüsselte Block genommen und in den neuen verschlüsselten Block mit reingerechnet. Sodass wenn du zweimal dasselbe verschlüsselst, was anderes rauskommt, weil es wurde ja in dem Block vorher was anderes gesendet und es wird mit reingerechnet. Und es setzt sich fort von Block zu Block zu Block zu Block.
Dann hast du sagen, keine zwei gleichen Blöcke? Ist das denn, du schickst mehrfach die gleichen Blöcke hintereinander?
Genau, man bekommt nie denselben Block raus, weil immer das von dem davor mit reingerechnet wird. Und jetzt gibt es dagegen aber einen Angriff dafür zu sorgen, dass doch wieder etwas rauskommt, was man kennt. Und das ist ein so genannten Chosen-Planetext-Attack. In der Praxis läuft also dieser BEAST-Angriff darauf hinaus und zu dem Server, zu dem ich eine verschlüsselte Verbindung habe, Daten sendet. Und zwar sendet der immer das Gleiche. Jetzt ändert sich das zwar von Block zu Block zu Block, aber wenn du vielleicht früher in der Schule mal gelangweilt mit deinem Taschenrechner umgespielt hast, irgendwas eingegeben hast, dann immer ist gleich gedrückt, dann kommen da verschiedene Zahlen raus und wenn man lange genug drückt, kommt immer wieder dieselbe Zahl raus. Das nennt man einen Fixpunkt dieser Funktion. Und nur hat dieses Zweifelblock-Chaining auch einen Fixpunkt. Also wenn man das Beruf lange genug macht, kommen irgendwann immer wieder dieselben Werte raus. Und das, was aus dem Block davor in den nächsten Reihen verschlüsselt wird, wird damit vorhersagbar. Jetzt so meine Theorie. In der verschlüsselten Verbindung von meinem Browser zum Server, das ist ja HTTP mit Keep Alive, das heißt, ich schicke ein HTTP-Request hin, kriege Daten zurück, schicke ein HTTP-Request hin, kriege Daten zurück. In dem HTTP-Request überträgt der Nutzer sein Cookie für die Webseite zu dem gesicherten Server. Das JavaScript kann jetzt dadurch, dass es irgendwelche Abfragen auch zu diesem Server generiert, da Daten einfügen. Das heißt, die schicken da Daten, ganz viel, immer dasselbe und dasselbe, bis ein Wert drauf kommt, der vorhersagbar wird und immer gleich. Und dann hören sie auf zu senden. Und dann klickt der User nochmal und schickt sein Cookie, dass es dann auch wieder CBC verschlüsselt. Aber der initiale Wert, der mit reingerechnet wird, der sogenannte Initialization Vector, den hat jetzt der Angreifer kontrolliert, weil er glaubt, dass er diese Chosen-Planetax-Attacke gemacht hat. Das heißt, er kann jetzt die verschlüsselten Daten nehmen. Und wenn er es schafft, in seiner verschlüsselten Verbindung zum Server, und das ist das Detail, was ich noch nicht ganz verstanden habe, auch zu demselben Wert zu kommen, dann kann er einfach meine verschlüsselten Daten senden, ohne dass er sie entschlüsseln können muss und mein Cookie landet beim Server in seiner Verbindung. Der Cookie repräsentiert die Nutzerrechte. Also wenn man sich auf einer Seite einloggt, dann bekommt man den Cookie zurück und man weist sich als der eingeloggte Nutzer ausdrücklich, dass man das Cookie zurückgibt. Das heißt, dadurch kann die laufende Session des Users übernommen werden.
Das heißt, das ist wie diese Fire-Ship-Attacke nur sozusagen kompliziert?
Nur kompliziert, weil das Cookie halt verschlüsselt ist und man muss halt ringsum so ein bisschen Mumbo Jumbo machen, damit man diesen verschlüsselten Block über eine sogenannte Replay-Attacke, also einspielen eines verschlüsselten Blockes, den man eigentlich gar nicht entschlüsseln kann.
Okay, warte mal, ich versuche mal zusammenzufassen, was du gesagt hast in Worten, die ich verstehe. Und du sagst, ob es richtig war. Also, und sozusagen nur grob, nur das grobe Konzept. Also, ich habe eine verschlüsselte Verbindung aufgebaut zu einem Server, den ich dann letztendlich sage, zu dem ich die Kommunikation abhören will. Ich schicke dem immer dasselbe, immer dasselbe, immer dasselbe, immer dasselbe, bis ich voraussagen kann, was als nächstes die Verschlüsselung tun wird. Dann nehme ich das Cookie des Users, dass er da gerade hinschicken will, und das schon verschlüsselt ist, schicke es aber sozusagen von mir aus dahin. Und dann denkt der Server, alles klar, ich bin der eigentliche User.
Total abgefahren.
Und wie kann man das jetzt lösen?
Also ich meine, du sagst am Anfang, da gibt es zwei Verfahren.
Halt, bevor wir das lösen, würde mich noch interessieren, dieser JavaScript, der musste, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, auf dem Rechner des Users sitzen. Genau. Wie kommt der da hin? Heißt, unterschieben, dass es reicht, ich sage, guck mal, User, hier gibt es Nacktbilder von Heino und alle klicken wie verrückt. Der ist dann irgendwann mal auf dieser Seite gewesen oder muss die Seite dann gleichzeitig offen sein, während er auf seiner Bank surft?
Die muss gleichzeitig offen sein, wahrscheinlich muss er sogar einen Bug finden, mit dem er in die andere Session reinkommt, damit dieser User, vielleicht auch nicht, also das hängt so ein bisschen vom Brose ab, wie das da mit den Sandboxingschranken ist.
Okay, also da ist schon noch mal ein bisschen Aufwand dahinter, um das sozusagen, um den Brose sozusagen so zum Absturz zu bringen, sage ich jetzt mal, dass das dann auch so ausgeführt wird, dass das alles klappt. Also ist es kompliziert?
Es ist auf jeden Fall kompliziert, das haben Leute vorgeführt, also wird es gehen. Wenn du mich vorher gefragt hättest, ob es geht, das hättest du gesagt, na, das ist zwar schon ein unschöner Angriff, aber der ist eher theoretisch.
Okay, und dieser Meinung bist du jetzt nicht mehr?
Nee, nachdem die es vorgeführt haben, ist völlig offensichtlich, dass es geht, ja.
Okay, was meinst du, wie lange wird das noch dauern, bis das, ich sag mal, allgemein gut ist und es auch im Aldi-Mahlwerk-Kit mit am Start ist?
Nicht länger als drei Monate.
Okay, was machen wir dann? Also ich meine, das ist ja ein bisschen unschön.
Also das Problem ist bekannt, also schon seit Längerem bekannt, dass es eine Schwachstelle dieses Cipher-Feedback-Modes ist und TLS 1.1 und TLS 2, also die neueren Versionen dieses Verschlüsselungsprotokolls, haben sie nicht was ausgedacht. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich hab's ehrlich gesagt nicht nachgeguckt, was sie getan haben. Was man zum Beispiel tun könnte, ist Counter-Mode verwenden, also sozusagen eine Zahl immer hoch zu zählen und die als Initialisierungsvektor für die Verschlüsselung zu nehmen, statt den Verschlüsselungblock davor.
Also es geht immer wieder darum, dass die Informationen, die ich übertrage, sich nicht gleichen und ich muss auf irgendeine Art und Weise dafür sorgen, dass sie immer unterschiedlich sind. Genau, so ein Counter tut das total problemlos. Und das zu sagen, es gibt also schon diese neuen Versionen dieser Verschlüsselung, aber die hat noch keiner benutzt oder wie? Das ist das Problem, also die Infrastruktur da draußen spricht zu 90 Prozent nur TLS 1.0.
Und das muss halt alles ausgetauscht werden, das heißt alle Server, alle Browser auf dem Planeten.
Aber das stelle ich mir jetzt sozusagen, also ich meine, okay, das sind halt viele Rechner, aber dann sagen halt irgendwie alle Serverbetreiber irgendwie hier, wir spielen das Update ein, Firefox, Opera, Chrome, weiss ja gar was, geben auch ein Update draus, alles gut. Hast du schon mal probiert in der Bank, den Produktivbetrieb davon zu überdenen, Patch einzuspielen auf dem System? Nein, aber ich bin ja auch Radiomoderator. Herr Urbach möchte an dieser Stelle etwas einfügen. Ich hab das mal probiert, das hat zweieinhalb Jahre gedauert. Hier behauptet einer im Chat, der Opera-Browser würde schon TLS 1.2 sprechen.
Ja, das sind die anderen zehn Prozent, die schon fertig sind.
So, das heißt also, bis das passiert ist, okay, die Frage ist ganz einfach. Du hast gerade gesagt, nach deiner Schätzung wird es drei Monate dauern, bis das Zeug so weit ist, dass es jeder benutzen kann, der nur halbwegs einen Plan hat. Wie lange wird es dauern, bis wir bei TLS 1.1 und 1.2 angekommen sind?
Da werden sich die Leute hoffentlich sputen. Also ich denke, auf der kleinen Seite wird es relativ schnell gehen. Also sowohl Firefox als auch Internet Explorer werden regelmäßig geupdatet und die haben einfach das Problem, dass die alle Naso an irgendwelche Bugs fixen müssen. Sind halt dazu übergegangen, dass es halt nicht mehr die Version des Browses gibt, sondern du kriegst ein wöchentliches Sicherheitsupdate. Die kleinen Seite wird vermutlich schnell gehen, auf der Serverseite könnte es ein bisschen länger dauern.
Was heißt ein bisschen länger, wo du gerade die Banken gesprochen hast? Also irgendwie so ein Jahr, fünf Jahre, zehn Jahre?
Es wird wohl bei manchen nur ein Jahr dauern oder zwei.
Oh, naja, ein bisschen Zeit.
Und die werden vor allem wohl wieder von den Klassiker haben, dass sie so Fallbacks haben, also Fallback-Modus, weil man das halt nicht deployen kann aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Und aus dem Grund dann halt in den alten Modus zurückgefallen wird, damit nicht das Web komplett zerbricht.
Und das ist ja auch immer eine Angriffsstelle. Ob ich es richtig verstanden habe, sagen wir, man spielt eine neue Technologie ein. Es gibt aber gleichzeitig ein Modus, wo man an einer Stelle sagen kann, ey, es ist cool, dass du eine neue Technologie hast, aber ich verstehe es noch nicht, mach mal bitte die alte. Und das lässt sich dann wiederum aussetzen für einen Angriff, okay? Ich meine, wenn jetzt alle Server sagen, wir machen jetzt nur noch eins, zwei, dann müssen auch alle, die mit diesen Server reden wollen, einen entsprechenden modernen Browser haben.
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, enthält TLS tatsächlich einen Protokollschutz gegen Downgrade-Attacks. Also bei SSL ging das noch, bei TLS geht es nicht mehr. Das merkst du, wenn einer dazwischen ist und versucht dir zu erzählen, dass er kein 1.1 spricht.
Also es ist sozusagen, wie schon als das Problem aufgetreten ist, theoretisch ist die Lösung bekannter, das macht einfach noch keiner. Okay, noch die letzte Frage zum BEAST, es ist ja irgendwie, das ist schon seit Längerem bekannt. Wie lange weiß man denn schon, dass das theoretisch geht?
Ja ungefähr seitdem TLS 1.1 geschrieben wurde, also so was wie 5 oder 6 Jahre.
Und warum kommt das jetzt erst hoch?
Na weil alle dachten, es sei theoretisch und 1.1 ist ja jetzt definiert als Standard und es wird halt irgendwann deployed und ist ja keine Eile und so.
Aber das heißt, wir wissen auch nicht, wie viele Leute das praktisch, vielleicht heimlich schon mal umgesetzt und angewandt haben.
Das weiß man nie, also so ähnlich ist es ja bei den Regierungen, also jede Regierung, die was auf sich hält, hat ihre eigene CA im Lande, die auch Staatsdinge tut und die stellen natürlich auch für die Laufe Interception-Zertifikate aus, da muss man sich gar keine Gedanken machen.
Das heißt, wenn man ganz sicher gehen will, eine gute Idee ist einen Browser in seinen Rechner zu untersuchen, um mal die ganzen Länderregierungen ausgestellten Zertifikate zu löschen? Ich halte dieses CA-Modell sowieso für kompletten Unsinn.
Also was funktioniert ist, it's only the trust and first use, und ich sehe jedes Mal denselben, persistente Pseudonyme sind eigentlich das Ding. Wenn ich jedes Mal denselben Key sehe, rede ich jedes Mal mit demselben.
Also wir signieren nicht mehr, sondern wir bauen einmal eine Kommunikation auf, nehmen das Zertifikat erstmal an, gucken, was da so passiert, und beim zweiten Mal gucken wir, ist es dasselbe wie beim ersten Mal, und wie hat er sich bis jetzt verhalten, und dann geht man davon weiter?
Ungefähr genau das. Also bei Banken wird es sicherlich eine gute Idee sein, wie das die Sparkasse gemacht hat, den Kunden einen Brief zu schicken, wo er hat der Fingerprint drin, steht bei der ersten Verbindung zur Seite, poppt dann halt das Fenster hoch, da steht der Fingerprint, den verbrechen wir mit seinem Ausdruck und sagt, jo, den glaube ich, und sag mir bitte Bescheid, falls ich das hier ändern sollte.
Okay, Andreas, an dieser Stelle vielen Dank dafür, dass du den Telefonjoker für die drei Verpeilten hier gemacht hast.
Ja, danke.
Und viel Spaß noch. So, sehr schön. Ach, wunderbar. Habt ihr eine 50-Prozentige, gibt's aber heute nicht mehr. Ich sag mal. Wir hatten ja schon mit Sigrid und Friedrich Kauder. Okay, wir haben jetzt, es ist schon häufiger aufgetaucht, dieses Ding mit dem Fingerprint. Also noch mal, wenn diese Verschüttung aufgebaut wird, werden Informationen ausgetauscht und die Richtigkeit dieser Informationen kann man mit einem sogenannten Fingerprint überprüfen. Heißt, es wird sozusagen eine Zahl durch wilde Mathematik ausgerechnet. Und wenn man diese Zahl von der anderen Seite schon bekommen hat, kann man nachprüfen, ob die übereinstimmt. Jetzt habt ihr schon mehrfach gesagt, und die Sparkasse hat es auch gemacht, wir drucken die Dinge einfach in einen Brief und schicken das an alle Leute. Was ist denn daran so schwer? Also warum wird das nicht gemacht?
Also das prinzipielle Problem ist ja...
Du, Funkami, ich nabrech dich ungern, aber das Mikro ist echt wichtig.
Und zwar ist das grundsätzliche Problem ja nicht, wenn wir beide zum Beispiel kommunizieren wollen, dann haben wir die Möglichkeit, uns auf ein Geheimnis zu einigen und wir wissen halt beide, wie das Geheimnis ist, um unsere Kommunikation zu verschlüsseln. Also das ist in dem Kontext eigentlich kein Problem. Das ist eigentlich kein Problem, weil Sie im Brief schicken können, ich bin Ihr Kunde und so weiter, das geht also ohne Probleme. Aber das eigentliche Problem ist, was tue ich mit Seiten, die jetzt mal hart gesprochen in China sind oder in Japan oder in den USA, also Seiten oder eben sozusagen Entitäten, zu denen ich eigentlich keinen Kontakt habe, wo ich keine Ahnung habe, wer das ist und so weiter.
Das ist schon das zweite Problem, das erste ist, warum machen die Banken das denn nicht? Also ich habe tatsächlich noch nie von irgendjemandem Papier gekriegt, also das ist doch irgendwie relativ billig, warum wird es nicht gemacht? Also ich bin ja Banker, gelernter. Oh Gott, wer hat dich hier rein gelassen? Ich bin ja Sparkassenkaufmann. Der Junge hat was Ordentliches geklärt.
Ja, durch Zufall.
Die Sache ist, die, wenn du jetzt eine Sparkasse oder eine andere Bank ihren Kunden einen Brief schickt mit diesem Fingerpen drinnen, die werden es nicht verstehen. Dann können wir noch eine Erklärung dazu schreiben, die Leute nehmen den Brief und packen ihn dann zur Seite. Und wenn die nie wieder auspacken, also die paar wenige, die es tun werden, das sind die, die es eh schon verstanden haben. Und das Problem liegt viel weiter vorgelagert schon. Das ist einfach ausgeschmissenes Geld für die Banken. Okay, also zwei Fragen dazu. A, könnte man es ja durchaus sagen, einfach so bauen, also softwaremäßig das sagen, dass das Ding abgefragt wird. Und B, selbst die Leute, die Bescheid wissen, also wo kriegen die denn dieses Ding her?
Das ist hier ein anderes Problem.
Naja, aber ist es denn möglich, kann ich zu meiner Bankin sagen, so Leute, ich hätte gerne auf einem Seitenkanal meine Fingerprint, wissen die überhaupt von der Rede? Probier das mal aus, es gibt Banken, die können das. Ich habe es bei meiner probiert, bin ich sowohl angerufen, bin aber auch mal in die Fiale und habe mal nach dem Fingerprint gefragt. Große Fragezeichen. Also da ist kein Problembewusstsein an der Stelle vorhanden, aber ich möchte ja auch widersprechen, eine Bank ist eine Sicherheit eklatant. So und wir könnten das jetzt gerade deinen Ex-Kollegen und anderen Banken auch erklären, dass das mit den Fingerprints eine gute Sache ist und schärft da weiter das Problembewusstsein bei euren Kunden. Ich meine, die Bank geht ja auch hin und sagt, oh jetzt machen wir keine Papiertanz mehr, jetzt müsstet ihr euch so ein komisches Gerät holen und da eure Karte reinstecken, dann könnt ihr wieder Online-Manking machen. So ja, die überreden jeden Kunden 10 Euro auszugeben, um sich ihr Gerät zu holen. Da können sie den Leuten auch mal so einen pädagogischen Auftrag erfüllen. Es ist unglaublich viel einfacher, den Leuten zu erklären, nimm dieses Gerät mit der Plastikkarte, als... Das ist nicht einfach.
Das ist für die Banker einfacher.
Ich hab das ja selbst erlebt, als ihnen zu erklären, dass sie auf ihren Fingerprint achten sollen. Was macht denn dieses Gerät eigentlich grundsätzlich anders? Das ist doch auch nur ein kleiner Computer, der eine verschlüsselte Verbindung aufbaut, oder nicht? Okay, der macht nichts anderes, oder wie?
Dieses kleine Gerät, von dem ich sprach, das war sozusagen eine ganz andere Ebene.
Man hat ja immer diese sechsstelligen Nummern von der Bank, mit denen man bestätigt, dass ich jetzt hier sozusagen eine TAN wegstreiche, eine Überweisung ausführe, dass man als Angreifer schon so eine TAN, und zwar genau die, die die Bank jetzt abstragt, dann auch abfischen muss.
Was ja kein Problem ist, wenn ich da gehe zu meinem Selben Kanal. Ich habe also sozusagen eine Information, die mir nicht über den selben Kanal gegeben wird, wie das, worüber ich gerade kommuniziere.
Naja, aber in dem Moment, wo der... Also klar, ich habe...
Eine Filiale ist ein Seitenkanal, ein Brief ist ein Seitenkanal.
Genau, aber mit den TANs, das funktioniert auch nicht. Sobald jemand diese verschlüsselte Verbindung abhört, kann er mir sozusagen vorspiegeln, okay, gib mal die TAN ein, dann mach ich das brav, dann hat er die richtige TAN und die so. Genau, das kann er tun. Ich habe übrigens damals den Fingerprint bekommen, als ich dann als Banker bei der Sparkasse Informatik angerufen habe und nach zweieinhalb Stunden Warteschleifen und Nachfrage habe ich dann die Fingerprints bekommen. Okay, für die Banken ist es anscheinend einfach billiger, die Ausfälle in Kauf zu nehmen, die es ja möglicherweise dadurch gibt und das sozusagen nicht zu kommunizieren. Ja, zumal auch einfach die Information für die selbstfahrende Bank nicht leicht zu bekommen, weil sie haben Dienstleister, die Portale betreiben, zum Beispiel bei den Sparkassen, da war es damals die Sparkasse Informatik, die gibt es so nicht mehr.
Und da jemanden zu erwischen, der einem das sagen kann, ist unglaublich schwer.
Versuch mal von Google die Fingerprints zu bekommen oder von Facebook oder von anderen großen Unternehmen die Fingerprints für ihre verschlüsselten Seiten. Das ist ein Riesenakt, das zu bekommen. Jetzt haben wir also sagen, zumindest für so große Sachen, die bekannt sind, das ist also eigentlich eine Lösung, nämlich gebt uns die Fingerprint über einen anderen Kanal, so ruft uns an, schreibt uns Briefe, weiß ja geier was. Mit Hasfokami, du hast jetzt gerade noch das andere Problem, nämlich möglicherweise möchte ich ja manchmal auch mit Leuten Informationen verschlüsselt austauschen, die aber jetzt nicht in der Nähe sind im Sinne von erreichbar bei einem anderen Kanal. Was ist denn da der Lösungsvorschlag?
Also eigentlich gibt es nicht wirklich eine Lösung. Es gibt nur eine Möglichkeit, die, ja, oder es gibt halt sozusagen mehrere Ansätze, bestimmte Teilprobleme zu lösen. Also ein Ansatz ist zum Beispiel zu sagen, also nehme ein Szenario, wie im Iran, wo ich sage, oder ok, Iran ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu groß, aber also irgendwas, wo ich sage, ich habe ein Zertifikat, was ich prüfen will und ich vertraue oder aber ich will erstmal sozusagen dem nicht blind vertrauen, sondern möchte gerne noch eine andere Möglichkeit haben, zu gucken, ob das vertrauenswürdig ist. Dann gibt es einen Ansatz, der mit Conversions nennt sich das, so eine Art, ja so Crowdsourcing betreibt, also sprich, man hat mehrere Services, die alle dieselbe Anfrage stellen und als Antwort eben sozusagen die Antwort zurückgeben, die sie bekommen haben. Und jetzt kann man anhand dessen sehen, ob sie alle dasselbe sehen. Das ist die eine Möglichkeit. Die andere Möglichkeit, wie das die IFF jetzt gerade machen will.
Darf ich kurz bei der schon mal anfangen? Also im Prinzip ist die Idee dahinter, ich frage die verschlüsselte Verbindung zu einem Server an. Der schickt mir ein Zertifikat, ich weiß nicht genau, ob das stimmt oder nicht, aber gleichzeitig fragen noch 10 andere Leute an.
Genau.
Und ich gehe davon aus, wenn jemand angegriffen wird, ist es nur einer oder zwei vielleicht?
Genau, weil wir über Netzwerke reden, das heißt, es gibt mehrere Wege, die zu dem Server führen. Und da könnte er irgendwo in diesem Netzwerk sein. Wenn er zum Beispiel in meinem Netzwerk ist und in den anderen Netzwerken nicht, dann können die anderen genauer sagen, hier, wir sehen ein anderes Zertifikat. Das heißt, deins muss irgendwie kaputt sein.
Auf jeden Fall ist irgendwas komisch so.
Genau, und das funktioniert halt in vielen, vielen Situationen, auch nicht in allen. Also es gibt Situationen, wo das halt nicht funktioniert.
Aber das würde zum Beispiel, ein bestimmter Zertifikat zur Stelle wurde gehackt, das könnte man damit auffangen, weil alle anderen sagen, ich habe hier von Equinox irgendwas, ein Zertifikat, du hast eins von Diginotar, das ist komisch. Genau. Was ist der Punkt, wo es nicht funktioniert?
Es funktioniert genau dann nicht, wenn zum Beispiel, ich vorher noch nie gesehen habe, ob es dieses Zertifikat auch irgendwo anders gibt. Das heißt, wenn, also es ist ein Extremfall, wenn jemand in dem Rechenzentrum, wo der Server ist, dort halt die Verbindung kontrolliert und er sozusagen, also jeder, der darauf zugreift, immer das Zertifikat sieht.
Und es gibt noch einen weiteren Fall, wo es nicht funktioniert, wenn zum Beispiel ein Anbieter, der mehrere Serverfarben hat, in den verschiedenen Rechenzentrums verschiedene Zertifikate von verschiedenen CAs verwendet. Ich bekomme unter Umständen immer ein anderes Zertifikat als derjenige, der in England sitzt oder in Brasilien. Und zwar immer. Aber dann trifft das ja auf alle Leute in Brasilien zu. Also ich meine, da ist die Frage, wie organisierst du so ein Netz? Das geht aber meistens schief, da gab es schon Versuche, die sind echt schiefgegangen. Aber ist der Ansatz sozusagen so zum Teil ein Vorteil, dass jemand gar nicht probieren müsste oder wäre es zumindest ein kleiner Sicherheitsgewinn?
Es ist ein kleiner Sicherheitsgewinn. Eine andere Möglichkeit, die es noch gibt, das wollte ich gerade ansetzen, das ist die Idee des IFF, zu sagen, man macht einfach eine Art Monitoring.
Du weißt, du weißt, wenn du mir erstmal was sagst, was keiner versteht, musst du erklären. Was ist der IFF?
Die IFF ist die Electronic Frontier Foundation. Das ist in den USA so eine Bürgerrechtsorganisation, die unter anderem so Dinge herausgibt wie SSL-Plugin, wer ist das nochmal? SSL-Anywhere.
Das erzwingt uns.
Genau, und sie wollen außerdem tracken, welche Domänen eigentlich welche Zertifikate haben. Weil man dann in dem Augenblick halt sieht, wenn sich irgendwas ändert und kann entsprechend sagen, Achtung, das Zertifikat ist halt irgendwie anders.
Die Frage ist auch, wie man dieses Tracking macht, dass man eben dann nicht nur auf die IFF vertrauen muss, dass das auch schön zentral funktioniert. Auch das ist schon mal gehörig schiefgegangen.
Da hat ein großer Dienst im Netz die Zertifikate getauscht.
Nein, das war das große G. Das kann mal passieren, man kann die Schlüsse sich ändern.
Und dann war plötzlich ein großer Alarm, Google sei gehackt.
Aber wenn das auf einmal bei allen auftritt, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass genau diese Zertifikate vorliegt? Nein, sie haben die Zertifikate über mehrere Wochen ausgetauscht in verschiedenen Rechenzentren.
Da muss Google auch mal loben.
Diese Sicherheit ist ja alles eine soziale Ebene. Das sind ja wirklich Verhaltensweisen von Administratoren, Nutzern und solchen Zwischenhändlern und Dienstleistern. Okay, dann würde ich sagen, es gibt auch dieses zweite Ding. Noch kurze Einschätzung von euch. Ist auch das was, was es lohnt auszuprobieren? Oder kann man das vom Tisch wischen?
Das ist schon okay. Das sind ja sozusagen viele Detailsachen, die halt so insgesamt das Problem nicht lösen, sondern halt Wolkeraus sind, im klassischen Sinne.
Okay, dann klären wir doch gleich nachher mal, ob wir das Problem überhaupt irgendwie gelöst kriegen. Vorher aber das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Datenverkehr.
In letzter Zeit ist ja so einiges bei ihnen passiert. Sie haben ein neues Album rausgebracht, Urlaub fürs Gehirn. Sie haben ein spezielles Konzert gespielt, nur für Frauen. Und sind mit ihrer Partei, die Partei, mich ins Abgeordnetenhaus gekommen. Aber manche Dinge, hallo du Trailersprecher du, alter F***er, ändern sich einfach nie.
Und das um ganz kurz vor halb 12. Nachrichten mit Philipp Borger. Die EU-Kommission hat Erleichter auf die deutliche Zustimmung des Bundestags zum erweiterten Euro-Rettungsschirm reagiert. EU-Parlamentspräsident Butzek sprach von einem wichtigen Schritt zur Wiederherstellung von Vertrauen in der Eurozone. Im Bundestag hatten heute 523 von 611 angewesenen Abgeordneten für den erweiterten Euro-Rettungsschirm gestimmt. Dabei wurde die symbolisch wichtige Kanzlermehrheit mit den Stimmen von Union und FDP erreicht. SPD und Grüne in Berlin streiten weiter über die angedachte Verlängerung der Autobahn 100 von Neukölln nach Treptow. Laut Kompromiss beider Parteien soll in Verhandlungen mit dem Bund untersucht werden, das Geld für die A100 in andere Verkehrsprojekte umzulenken. Wenn das aber nicht gelingt, wird der Autobahnabschnitt gebaut, so erklärt es die SPD. Die Grünen beharren darauf, dass sie keinen Koalitionsvertrag unterschreiben, in dem der Ausbau der A100 vereinbart wird. Ob die Grünen neuer Regierungspartner der SPD in Berlin werden und Koalitionsverhandlungen beginnen wollen, entscheiden sie morgen auf einem Parteitag. Nach der tödlichen Hetzjagd auf einen 23-Jährigen in Berlin sitzt nur noch ein Verdächtiger in Untersuchungshaft. Der Haftbefehl gegen einen 22-Jährigen sei aufgehoben worden, teilte die Staatsanwaltschaft mit. Diesem Mann könne nach der Rekonstruktion des Falles auf dem Kaiserdamm keine Beteiligung an der Jagd auf das getötete Opfer nachgewiesen werden. Es werde aber weiter wegen gefährlicher Körperverletzung gegen ihn ermittelt. Vor knapp zwei Wochen war ein junger Mann auf der Flucht vor Schlägern aus dem U-Bahnhof Kaiserdamm auf die Straße gerannt, wo er von einem Auto erfasst und tödlich verletzt wurde. Die Zahl der Arbeitslosen ist im September auf den niedrigsten Stand seit 20 Jahren gesunken. Wie zuletzt 1991 waren nach Angaben der Bundesagentur für Arbeit knapp 2, 8 Millionen Menschen als erwerbslos registriert. Bundesarbeitsagentur Chef Weise sagte, die Finanzmarktkrise sei noch nicht am Arbeitsmarkt angekommen. Bundesarbeitsministerin von der Leyen warnte angesichts der positiven Entwicklung vor zu viel Optimismus. In der Fußball Europa League hat Schalke 04 das erste Spiel unter der Leitung seines neuen Trainers Hyb Stevens gewonnen. Gegen den israelischen Meister Makabi Haifa siegte Schalke 3 zu 1 und Hannover 96 hat am Abend auch gewonnen und zwar gegen den ukrainischen Club Vorsklap Poltava mit 2 zu 1. Der Zeittemperatur an zwischen 11 und 15 Grad in Berlin und Brandenburg. Keine Wolken, überall trocken. Tiefst werde heute Nacht noch möglich 9 bis 6 Grad. Morgen gibt es wieder weiter schönen Sonnenschein bei Temperaturen von bis zu 26 Grad. Auch Samstag und Sonntag soll gutes Wetter sein. A10, westlicher Berliner Regen Richtung Drei-Eck-Hamburg, zwischen Spandau und Drei-Eck-Hafe-Land fährt ein Schwertransport, den könnt ihr nicht überholen und deswegen gibt es Stau. Bitte fahrt vorsichtig an das Stauende heran. A10, südlicher Regen Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz, zwischen Dreieck Nutetal und Ludwigsfelde West ist auf der A10 bis 6 Uhr früh nur eine Spur frei. A10, westlicher Berliner Regen Richtung Dreieck-Potztamm, zwischen Großkreuz und Dreieck Werder ist die rechte Spur gesperrt wegen eines defekten Fahrzeugs. A24, Berlin Richtung Hamburg, zwischen Dreieck-Hafe-Land und dem Dreieck-Wittstockdosse fährt ein Schwertransport, LKW, könnt ihr nicht überholen. Berlin, A100, der Stadtring Richtung Wedding, zwischen Buschkrugallee und Gradestraße ist die rechte Spur gesperrt und in Richtung Neukölln ist der Tunnel Innsbrucker Platz gesperrt, noch bis morgen früh. Berlin Tiergartenstraße des 17. Juni, zwischen Großem Stern und Brandenburger Tor noch bis zum 5. Oktober Vollsperrung in beiden Richtungen. Auch die Iza Gravienstraße ist gesperrt sowie teilweise die Ebertstraße. Zur Berliner S-Bahn bis Betriebsschluss sind zwischen Grünau und Adlershof Busse im Einsatz.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wir machen weiter mit den Datenverkehr. EU-Kommissarin fordert mehr Einfluss von Regierungen auf Internetinfrastrukturen. Aus dem Internet Governance Forum in Nairobi forderte Nelly Groß erneut, dass die sogenannte Internetverwaltung ICAN besser mit Regierungen zusammenarbeiten soll. Die ICAN ist zuständig für Namens- und Adressräume und hatte zuvor die Domainendung.xxx für Rotlichtinhalte beschlossen. Microsoft hat mit Samsung einen Patentdeal abgeschlossen, ähnlich wie mit HTC schon vor einem Jahr. Endlich kann der Riese aus Redmond an den Verkäufen der beiden größten Android-Telefonhersteller in den USA mitverdienen. Um welche Teile es des Microsoftschen Patentportfolios sich handelt, ist zur Stunde noch unklar. Und Nordafrika, bei Verwendung von Internet ist hier besondere Vorsicht geboten. Denn der Datenverkehr wird durch Überwachungstechnologie stark eingeschränkt. Auch SSL-Verbindungen sind betroffen. So werden neben klassischer Abhörtechnologie wie Wanzen- und Telefonüberwachung auch Datenverkehrsfilter eingesetzt. Meiden Sie diesen Datenverkehrsbereich am besten großräumig. Philipp Orga mit dem Datenverkehr, vielen Dank.
Und wenn ihr mal ganz anders Radio hören wollt, mit jeder Menge Live-Bands und schrägen Aktionen zum Mitdenken und Machen, dann hört doch mal ganz anders Radio bei KenFM. Immer sonntags ab 14 Uhr auf RETT.
Heute Chaos Radio, mein Name ist Markus Richter und zu Gast sind Leute mit und um den Chaos Computer Club in Gestalt von einem Herren, der sich Wetterfrosch nennt und sein Mikrofon gerade erst angemacht hat. Fukami?
Hallo.
Und der Herr Obach.
So, wir reden heute hier über SSL, über Verschlüsselt Internetverbindung und wir haben jetzt den Zeitpunkt überschritten, wo es Sinn macht, dass ich noch mal erkläre, was wir schon alles gemacht haben. Das heißt, ich empfehle euch, wenn ihr es gerade einschaltet und denkt so, ah, dieser Prowler irgendwie, der macht normalerweise diese Verschlüsselt-Verbindung zu meiner Onlinebank und mich würde es interessieren, aber ich verstehe nicht ganz, was sie da reden. Hört euch den Podcast zu dieser Sendung an, den gibt es unter fritz.de relativ bald nach der Sendung oder unter chaosradio.ccc.de dann ein bisschen später oder ihr bleibt jetzt dran und vielleicht kriegt es ja doch irgendwie noch einen Sinn, was ja alles besprochen wird. Wir kommen jetzt zu der Ebene, die sehr spannend ist. Wir haben die ganze Zeit darüber gesprochen, dass es Probleme gibt und wir haben gerade ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, dass man diese Probleme im Einzelnen lösen kann, indem man sozusagen so kleine Dinge tut, wo Leute vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr mit zugucken, dass das irgendwie alles seine Richtigkeit hat. Gibt es sonst noch Lösungen, die irgendwie ansetzt sind, wo ihr sagt, das ist interessant, das könnte SSL noch sicherer machen? Oder?
Also wir hatten noch eine Sache schon angesprochen und das wurde auch vorhin schon mal erwähnt im Kontext mit einem Plugin und zwar Https bzw. Public Key Pilling. Die Idee dahinter ist, wenn ich das erste Mal zu einer Seite komme und sage, das ist die Domain, die ich auch haben will, vertraue dann dem Zertifikat und tracke nur noch, ob es Änderungen gibt.
Okay, dann klammert man das Problem aus, wie ich beim ersten Mal feststelle, ob es die richtige Seite ist, aber ich kann zumindest feststellen, ob sich dann irgendwas ändert.
Und ich kann natürlich als Betriebssystem oder Softwarehersteller, der dort die Verbindung selbst kontrolliert, ja fest hinterlegen, welche CA für welche Domäne zuständig ist. Das heißt, ich kann dort bestimmte Angriffe einfach aus dem Weg gehen, weil ich immer sagen kann, ich weiß, was ich hier zu erwarten habe. Das heißt für Google, für Apple, für Microsoft und so sind das halt auf jeden Fall gangbare Wege, um zumindest diese Art der Kommunikation abzusichern.
Und das würde das Problem komplett klären oder?
Das klärt es für bestimmte Sachen, also für sozusagen Updates. Das wäre eine Sache, die ja schon wichtig ist. Wenn ich sage, ich will zum Beispiel CRs rausschmeißen, die halt nicht vertrauenswürdig sind oder die gehackt wurden, dann habe ich immer einen Kanal, über den ich das machen kann, wo ich sicher sein kann, dass dort halt tatsächlich die Daten rübergehen, die...
Da stellt quasi der Google-Browser fest, dass diese Aussage nur von Google getätigt werden.
Genau, das ist auch der Grund, warum es überhaupt im Iran aufgefallen ist, weil Google, weil Chrome tatsächlich dieses HTTPS-Pinningen hat und dort festgestellt hat, na, huch, hier wird irgendwie ein anderes Zertifikat benutzt als das, was eigentlich in dem Browser fest hinterlegt ist. Und da hat dann jemand gesagt, okay, hat sich das genau angeguckt und hat geguckt, wie dann eigentlich die CA und diese ganze Trust Chain eigentlich aussieht.
Jetzt hast du gerade irgendwie Updates erwähnt, spielt, also für die Leute, die das vielleicht noch gar nicht wissen, spielt bei Softwareupdate, also die sich die meisten Programme automatisch zum Netz ziehen, spielt ja dieses SSL und diese verschlüsselte Verbindung auch eine Rolle?
Ja, wir haben ja schon mal gesagt, dass es ja nicht nur um Verschlüsselung geht, sondern auch um Integrität. Das heißt, dass man auf der anderen Seite den Server hat, den man halt auch wirklich haben will.
Stell dir vor, jeder kann behaupten, du müsstest jetzt mal dein Firefox updaten, am besten hier, gleich sofort von mir. Dann hole ich dir alles in dein Firefox unter, was ich an deinem Computer anstellen will. Das heißt, du sagst, das ist ein weiteres Feld, wo das eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Also wir haben nicht nur die Verbindung beim Websurfen, sondern auch wenn unsere Programme sich updaten. Das ist auch wichtig. Was gibt es noch für Felder? Bei Mails. Bei Mails? Also zum Beispiel E-Mail-Zugang, hier Pop3, SMTP sind da die Schlagwörter, die man als Protokolle benutzt, um seine E-Mails mit Mail-Programmen abzurufen.
Da kann man auch sagen, ich möchte eine gesicherte Verbindung mit meinem Mailserver, was zu empfehlen ist.
Dann sind zumindest die E-Mails auf dem Weg von meinem Computer zu meinem Mailserver, nicht darüber hinaus zu den anderen verschlüsselt. Und das funktioniert auch mit SSL. Und da haben wir natürlich genau dieselben Probleme, wie wir jetzt schon erwarten haben.
Der Mojava zum Beispiel oder IHC über SSL. Also es ist schon eine sehr, sehr, sehr fundamentale Technik. Also sehr viel in diesem Netz. Also an irgendwie treffig, der verschlüsselt ist, nutzt SSL.
Herr Obach hat noch? Nicht zu vergessen, die ganzen Webmail-Programme. Also, wir haben hier natürlich GMX, Web.de und wie sie alle heißen, gibt es natürlich auch noch im Ausland verschiedene Dienste. Auch die funktionieren mit SSL.
Genau, also es gibt sozusagen das ZwangssSSL, sozusagen wenn eine Website dich dazu zwingt, die Verschlüsselung zu nutzen, das tut deine Bank.
Klar, weil die sagt irgendwie hier, unverschlüsselt einloggen, geht mal gar nicht. Und auch die ganzen Webmailer, wie du sagst, erzwingen auch immer diese SSL-Verbindung mittlerweile. Und da, der Kurzabriss sieht es halt so aus, jeder, der so eine Zertifizierungsstelle ist, kann behaupten sozusagen für deinen Mailprovider zuständig zu sein. Und da wäre dieses Pending, was vor kam, gesagt, naja, vielleicht nur bestimmte Stellen für bestimmte Bereiche im Netz. Und ich hatte vor dem Vorschlag gesagt, ja Gott, wir könnten bei CCC auch so eine Zertifizierungsstelle irgendwie aufmachen, aber würdest du dir für alte Webseiten vertrauen? Nee, also würde ich persönlich selbst nur für CCC-Domains vertrauen.
Und da hatte ich gerade eine Raucherpause, die den philosophischen Ausblick, ja das Vertrauen im Internet kann nur dem Vertrauen in real life, im echten Leben folgen. Aber das geht halt nicht in dem Internet. Ja, in dem Internet ist das schwierig.
Wir haben da 200 Stellen in unserem Browser und da wäre die radikale Ansage, schmeißt alle raus und stellt nur die einen, die ihr haben wollt und dann könnt ihr mit eurer Bank erstmal nicht reden. Dann kann ich aber auch nicht mit dem lustigen Dinge aus Bangladesch versenden, Online-Shop reden. Aber nein, du kannst halt immer sagen, okay, das war sozusagen die Philosophie eben, wir vertrauen auf den ersten Angebot, auf den ersten Angebot, den Schlüssel, beim ersten Aufruf der Webseite, ohne sozusagen Seitenkanal zu nutzen, um ihn zu verifizieren, ins Blaue hinein, wir glauben an das Gut der Menschen, die erste Verbindung wird schon stimmen, Hauptsache ich merke, sobald sich der Schlüssel ändert. Insofern ist halt dieses ins Blaue hinein, das klingt nicht gut, wenn es um Sicherheit geht.
Ich bin ja immer Freund vom Papier.
Bei Mails hat man das gleiche Problem mit dem Schlüsselaustausch, wenn man die Mail als solches verschlüsseln will. Da gehen viele Leute dazu, über ihren Fingerprint, diese Prüfziffer, die man mit dem Schlüssel überprüfen will, auf ihre Visitenkarten zu drucken.
Eine Zeitung wäre da nur ein Beispiel, Drucksachen, Visitenkarten.
Wenn eine Firma Interesse hat, dass ihre Kunden oder Interessierten wirklich auch mit der Firma sicher den Kontakt aufnehmen, dann sollte sie ihren Fingerprint auch auf Drucksachen schreiben.
Und jetzt ist das pädagogisch sehr ausklangend.
Achtet mehr auf die Keys, die euch untergegült werden. Und lasst das nicht diese Zertifizierung stellen. Also reden wir jetzt irgendwie davon, dass es in der Kleineranzeigenabteilung der großen Tageszeigen, demnächst zu sagen, eine Fingerprint-Abteilung gibt, wo irgendwie alle Banken... Wenn sie Bock drauf haben, aber sie drucken noch nicht mal die Lottozahlen mit Gewehr ab. Insofern weiß ich nicht, ob sie Fingerabdrücke mit Gewehr abdrücken wollen. Also juristisch würde er wahrscheinlich da auch stehen ohne Gewehr, weil Bebel das schon verantworten. Aber wenn in der Morgenpost dasselbe steht, wie im Tagesspiegel, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, so viele Druckereien. Das ist die Rettung des Verlagswesens.
Endlich haben sie einen Grund zum Leben.
Sehr schön. Im Verlauf der Sendung, ich habe euch auch immer ein bisschen gebremst, und auch jetzt mit Twitter und im Chat klang immer so an, also eigentlich kann man ein bisschen was machen, aber im Prinzip ist das ganze System broken. Es ist technisch eigentlich ziemlich gut. Ihr seid doch keine Juristen, wieso denn jetzt jaen? Kannst du einmal eine klare Antwort bekommen? Da husche ich nochmal kurz den Ohr vor. Technisch, wie SSL an sich funktioniert, ist ganz gut durchdacht. Wir haben da diese eine Lücke, die Andreas am Telefon vorhin ausgeführt hat, die ist reparierbar. Die ist zwar eklatant, aber an sich SSL ist gut. Das ganze Drumherum, wie diese Zasifizierungsstellen agieren, das ist der Bereich, wo wir sagen, da mussten wir irgendwie vorankommen. Und ja, welche Lösung haben wir da? Lösung gibt es dann auch wie in einem kleinen eigentlich. Das haben wir jetzt auch in Nordafrika festgestellt. Wir haben da ein Land, gerade eine Revolution laufen, und die hatten plötzlich halt diese kaputten SSL-Zertifikate. Und wir haben ihnen jetzt ein Plugin geschrieben, für ihren Firefox und ihren Chrome, dass sie, wenn sie auf eine verschlüsselte Verbindung gehen, das Zertifikat, das sie präsentieren wird, erstmal bei uns anfragen, also bei uns als Aktivistengruppe, ob das das ist, dass es auch sein soll. Das wird also überprüft. Aber auch da ist hier eine Vertrauensfrage. Diese Menschen vertrauen uns, dass wir da jetzt nicht die falsche Zertifikate draufschieben. Das ist also auch nur eine temporäre Insellösung. Aber auch da folgt das Vertrauen des Real-Lives wieder, weil die kennen sich aus irgendwelchen anderen Zusammenhängen. Die kennen uns aus anderen Zusammenhängen, weil wir Dinge getan haben für sie oder mit ihnen zusammen. Und da haben wir das Vertrauen gewonnen.
Und sie vertrauen da dieser Instanz, wie momentan ja auch die Browser einer Instanz vertrauen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Problem wird einfach verschoben. Auch ihr seid natürlich auf die ganze Art und Weise angreifbar. Auch bei euch könnte man sich einschleichen, auch euch könnte man hacken. Also wie gesagt, das heißt letztendlich, gibt es keine Sicherheit, oder wie? Es ist halt das Vertrauen. Ich meine, du setzt gerade beim Webbrowser an, du setzt darauf, dass die Microsoft, die du in der Internet Explorer benutzt, oder diese Mozilla Community, diese freie Softwarejungs, die ja auch so ein bisschen chaotisch sind, schon das Richtige tun. Also erst einmal, dass die da keine Scheiße einpatchen und zum anderen, dass die sozusagen diese Vertrauensinstanzen auch wirklich Vertrauenswürdige akzeptieren und dass das da auch alles sozusagen technisch koscher abläuft. Und ja, also es funktioniert ja gerade irgendwie und die Frage ist, ist es den Leuten gewahr, wie es funktioniert? Das ist genau die Frage, die ich gerade habe. Also normalerweise sind ihr vom guten an am Computer gewöhnt, also ja oder nee. Aber das heißt, entnehme ich euren Worten, sozusagen im Großen und Ganzen, gibt es keinen Punkt, wo man sagen kann, das ist wirklich, wirklich sicher?
Nein, also genau diesen Punkt ist es nicht.
Was denn ihr sagt, Gott?
Nein, es gibt keinen Punkt, wo man sagen kann, alles ist sicher.
Jeder Innenminister wird ihnen das bestätigen.
Also weil man an dem Punkt, gibt es keine einfache Lösung. Das ist einfach die Sache. Und die Konsequenz ist tatsächlich zu sagen, dass wir uns daran gewöhnen müssen, an diesem Punkt mit einer gewissen Unsicherheit zu leben.
Okay, also heißt das dann im Umkehrschluss auch zu sagen, wir können es einfach gleich lassen?
Nein, also es gibt schon Möglichkeiten, spezielle Bereiche wirklich gut abzusichern. Das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Kommunikation innerhalb einer Firma habe, ist das eigentlich nicht problematisch. Weil da kann ich halt, ich habe dort ein Vertrauensverhältnis, was dem entspricht, was ich eben tatsächlich auch habe. Das heißt, ich habe einen Admin, der mir irgendwie ein Zertifikat baut für eine Seite, auf die greife ich zu. Die ist in meinem Browser oder in einer anderen Software drinnen und kann sicher sein, dass das das Zertifikat für den Dienst ist. Punkt.
Also ich möchte dann wieder zu dieser Fahrradschlossmetapher zurückkehren. Das ist ja auch so, da sagt man so, okay, wenn du ein Fahrrad kaufst, legst du irgendwie zu 10 Prozent des Kaufpreises in Fahrradschloss an. Besser zwei von Herstellern und so. Und dann ist immer noch klar, auch da gibt es Leute, die das aufkriegen, aber man macht es halt einfach ein bisschen schwerer, das zu machen, ist es dann trotzdem, wobei man im Klaren das Fahrrad kann trotzdem geklaut werden, aber unternimmt halt alles, damit es nicht passiert. Ist das sozusagen ungefähr das, wie man auch in Zukunft im Websurf?
Ja, also vor allem für die Leute, die normal User sind, sage ich mal, weil die Möglichkeiten, das zu kontrollieren, was man dort eigentlich wissen muss, um das ordentlich zu machen, das ist schon etwas, was man in so einfachen Interfaces eigentlich nicht unterbringen kann. Und das ist eigentlich das Problem. Also man kann als Profi, sage ich mal, in einem Umfeld, was man sehr gut kennt, kann man ein sehr hohes Maß an Sicherheit herstellen. Aber es geht halt nicht ohne weiteres für den Alltag im Web, sage ich mal.
Also okay, das heißt, wir als Normal User, wir kriegen das auf jeden Fall nicht hin, dass du das alles genau kontrollierst, dass es eben ganz stark kommt. Das heißt, okay, Punkt eins, wir müssen damit leben, es gibt keine Garantie, dass die verschlüsselte Verbindung tatsächlich verschlüsselt ist. Aber, sagt ihr, trotzdem ist es eine gute Idee, die anzumachen, weil das schon mal schwerer abzuhören, als wenn sie gar nicht verschlüsselt ist. Und ich überlege gerade noch, diese Klischee-Situation ist ja irgendwie, mit euch ein Normal User sitzt vor dem Bildschirm, macht Online-Banking und der Hausnacht sagt so, bitte guck, dass es verschlüsselt ist. Beim Banking sagt man auch immer so, okay, guck immer mal deinen Kontostand an, damit du irgendwie weißt, ob da jemand komische Dinge abbucht. Das heißt, wir kommen niemals, zumindest mit diesem SSL-System, an einen Punkt, wo das nicht mehr nötig ist. Denn die Kontrolle, ob in meiner Umwelt irgendwas schief läuft, ist immer eine gute Idee.
Ja, genau.
Es ist aktuell im System halt so, dass jeder der Zertifizierungsstellen jeden anderen unterschreiben kann. Und ich meine, da hat jeder dieser Zertifizierungsstellen, ich habe jetzt hier gerade mal den Kommentar, es sind über 700 und nicht 200, wenn man Firefox und Interexplorers zusammenzählt, in der Lage, gerade für jeden andere Domain irgendwie was auszustellen. Ich glaube, wenn das rauskommt oder sie das tun, dann verspielen sie sich das. Aber ich glaube, das ist gerade der Punkt, an dem man da steht. Das heißt aber auch zu sagen, dass man sich Gedanken macht an Stellen, wo es wichtig ist. Aber man hat ja immer zu sagen, als Gegenstück, wenn man sagt, okay, diese Technologie ist grundsätzlich kaputt. Das heißt, sie müssen sich die ganze Zeit mit dem Handy über dem Kopf rumsetzen und sagen, nein, meine Facebook-Verbindung wird abgehört und mein Mail wird abgehört. Das ist aber auch nicht der Fall.
Nein, also im richtigen Fall.
Kommt auch ein welcher. Kommt auch, in welchem Land du gerade lebst.
Das ist auch dabei glaube ich ganz wichtig. Ich glaube, dass in Deutschland das Abhören relativ gering ausfällt. Während gerade in China oder Iran als krasses Beispiel einfach nichts mehr sicher ist. Das heißt aber, diese ganzen Angriffe, das ist schon auch noch technischer Aufwand. Wir sind noch nicht bei dem Stadium. Mehr oder weniger.
Solange man noch sowas machen kann wie, ich habe einen Faff-Icon im Browser, was aussieht wie ein Schlüssel, der zeigt, die Seite ist sicher und ein User lässt sich davon austricksen, ist das Ganze zum Thema Zertifikat und sowieso hinfällig.
Also wenn man es will, geht es. Aber man muss es zumindest noch wollen. Das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass das komplette System vollautomatisch offen ist. Und zu sagen, sowieso nichts funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, man kann ein gewisses Maß an Sicherheit herstellen. Und die Frage ist immer, was man eigentlich erreichen will. Das ist ja ohnehin bei elektronischer Kommunikation immer so, dass man eigentlich genau sagen muss und genau erkennen muss, mit welchem Aufwand man welche Art von Sicherheit erreicht.
Okay, man muss sagen, beliebe schwer und hofft dann, dass das reicht. Gibt es denn einen Ausblick oder eine Vision, ob dieses System mal gänzlich abgelöst wird? Oder wird das sozusagen ein Rumdoktern und Verbessern von den Sachen, die da jetzt schon existieren?
Also ich bin vorhin auf einen Blogpost aufmerksam gemacht worden von Sweatpost. Da geht es um ein Interview mit Ron Rives, das R&RSA. Und er wird gefragt, wie er denn das sieht, von jetzt an in zwei Jahren, bzw. was er sieht, wie das sich entwickelt. Und Ron Rives sagt, fragen Sie mich einfach in zwei Jahren nochmal. Weil dort die Diskussion halt sehr, sehr groß ist sozusagen in der Krypto-Community. Und wir hier und da eben Lösungen sehen werden, die bestimmte Probleme lösen und bestimmte Trust-Modelle werden auch sicherlich ausprobiert usw. Und es wird dort eine ganze Menge passieren. Wir werden aber so schnell keinen Ersatz für dieses ganze System haben.
Also muss ich überlegen, wenn man es ersetzen will.
Selbst wenn wir eine Lösung gefunden haben, haben wir das gleiche Problem wie mit TLS. Es muss ersetzt werden, es muss deployed werden überall.
Das ist ein Riesenaufwand.
Das Problem ist ja nicht SSL an sich, sondern das Drumherum. Das Soziale wird mit den ganzen Schlüsseln umgegangen. Und auch wenn du dir ein neues, perfektes technisches System ausdenkst, hast du wieder dasselbe Problem. Woher kommt das Vertrauen? An wen? An wen wird es gerichtet und gesteckt? Das sind halt die Dinge, über die du das unterhalten musst. Und wenn jetzt jeder einfach den Computer benutzt, als würde es schon klappen, dass er es tut, und dann macht man was Komisches und redet mit niemandem darüber, dann gibst du dich in die Abhängigkeit. Aber wenn ich merke, bei mir ist das Zertifikat plötzlich anders und das erwarte ich da nicht. Und ich kenne einen anderen Nutzer, nämlich dich von derselben Webseite. Und ich frage dich, ob es bei dir auch anders ist. Dann haben wir die Chance, solche Sachen aufzudecken. Klar, für einen Autonomal-User ist das nichts. Deswegen hatten wir jetzt die Ansätze mit Plugins, Convergence IO hieß das eine oder Certifikat Patrol, was sich zumindest über Änderungen warnt. Und wo man halt so einen Austausch zwischen Nutzern schafft und eben Ungereimtheiten schneller auffallen. Das ist glaube ich schon die Stoßrichtung, in die wir jetzt am ehesten übergehen können. Warte mal, wollt ihr mir jetzt ernsthaft erklären, wir haben zwei Stunden über ein technisches Problem diskutiert und die Lösung ist nachdenken und miteinander reden? Das hätten wir auch schneller haben können, verehrte Damen und Herren. Okay, aber sehr schön. Wenn ihr diese Sendung also jetzt gerade eingeschaltet habt, kann ich euch nur empfehlen, hört nochmal den Podcast, der wird sehr gut erklärt, naja, hoffe ich zumindest, ohne mich selber genug loben zu wollen, wie SSL im groben Konzept funktioniert und was die Probleme damit sind. Zu Gast waren der Herr Wetterfrosch, der Herr Fuqam und der Herr Obach. Vielen Dank dafür nochmal. Und wir wollen das Ende nochmal benutzen, um ein bisschen Werbung zu machen für die Dinge, die der Chaos Computer Club so tut in näherer Zukunft. Da stehen zwei Dinge an, habe ich mir sagen lassen, eins bald und eins recht bald. Also ganz bald, sehr bald, der Kongress, Ende des Jahres wieder zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr im BCC in Berlin.
Vier Tage, zum 28.
Mal, 27. bis 30. Dezember. Wie werden dieses Mal die Tickets verlost?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Aber wenn ihr auf jeden Fall eins haben wollt, dann müsstet ihr mit einem richtig guten inhaltlichen Beitrag euch einfach in den nächsten zwölf Tagen noch als Referent melden. Und wenn der wirklich richtig gut ist, dann habt ihr damit euer Ticket sicher. Was heißt eigentlich richtig gut? Also die Beiträge, mit denen man sich da anmeldet zum Kongress, muss das irgendwas mit meinem Rechner zu tun haben? Nö, wir sind da relativ offen, auch in künstlerischen Ambitionen und auch mal ganz andere Disziplinen kennenzulernen. Da musst du jetzt nicht nur der Obernerd, aber Hauptsache ist es halt für die Teilnehmer irgendwie interessant und wir haben da meist doppelt so viele Einreichungen, Plätze frei. Deswegen, wenn es abgelehnt wird, dürft ihr uns das nicht überlegen. Okay, das geht also, noch 12 Tage hat man Zeit, dass wir events.ccc.de machen.
Genau, da gibt es die Info und dann gibt es halt ein System zum Anmelden. Die zweite Veranstaltung ist übermorgen am Samstag im Stadtbad Wedding. Da ist 30 Jahre.CCC. Party.
Wir hatten Geburtstag vor zwei Wochen. Sieht man euch gar nicht an, das Alter? Was wird da passieren auf der Party?
Musik, Getränke, Musik.
Wird es Chunk geben oder ist das irrelevant?
Es wird Chunk geben. Das ist selbstverständlich.
Alles klar, sehr schön. Das war dann wirklich alles, was wir heute mit euch zu teilen hatten. Es war mein Vergnügen. Vielen Dank auch an die Leute im Chat, Twitter, Netz, was auch immer, wo ihr kommentiert habt. Und wie gesagt, den Podcast gibt es dann demnächst auf fritz.de. Und ich stelle gerade fest... Wie muss das für die Leute klingen, die den Podcast hören? Das unglaubliche... Oh Gott, Inception! Es sind jetzt noch mehr Minuten Zeit als der letzte Track, den wir normalerweise haben. Wollen wir noch so lange Unsinn reden? Oder soll ich zwei Musiken spielen? Ja, Mühe!
Wollen wir noch über den Kauder oder zu den Piraten? Nicht über die Piraten.
Nein, nicht über deine Arbeit.
Über die reden wir ja nicht.
Über welchen Kauder denn? Siegfried oder Volker?
Beide.
Siegfried, das ist schon echt eine harte Nummer. Man muss überlegen, dass der Mann...
Ich weiß gar nicht, was seine Position ist in Sachen Urheberrechte.
Ich glaube, der ist beim Innenausschuss. Wenn er dann mit so Ansagen kommt, wie ich habe Urheberrechte erworben, dann ist das halt schon ganz schön schräg. Das will ich aber auch mal machen.
Ich will auch mal Urheberrechte kaufen. Es wurde ja gesagt, ich habe auf Twitter irgendwann gelesen, er zählt jetzt quasi schon die Zeit runter, bis ein Wiki entsteht, wo die Leute mal gucken, ob die akademischen Arbeiten von Herrn Kauder nicht vielleicht... Ich dachte, wir machen erst mal das Wiki auf, Urheberrechte von allen Politiker-Websites zu checken. Das kann man natürlich auch gerne machen. Der Herr Guttenberg ist ja auch, ne? Ja genau, der ist jetzt Staatsmann. In verantwortungsvoller Diskussion. Er ist an einem Army-Think-Tank als Distinguished Statesman. Also ein angesehener Staatsmann. Dings nach Atlantikbrücke. Genau, oder Council for Formulation, Atlantikbrücke.
Wunder, Wunder.
Checkt mal diese komischen Politiker.
Und die sind ja froh über alles, was sie kriegen können aus dem Ausland. Okay, dann beschließen wir die Sendung damit. Wir haben jetzt noch zum Schluss gelernt. Wenn ihr euch für Technik interessiert und wisst, was SSL ist, und gerne an den Computer herumschraubt, dann kommt ihr möglicherweise ins Radio. Und wenn ihr eure Doktor-Abwart abschreibt, dann kommt ihr nach amerikanen Singtanks. Damit möchte ich dann noch Flo Heiler übergeben, der euch den Rest der Nacht mit Punk-Musik erfreuen wird. Und ich verabschiede mich von den drei Gästen nochmal. Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart. Gerne. Und dann bleibt mir nur noch eins zu sagen, und das ist, lasst euch nicht überwachen. Und macht immer schön eure Backups.